the FBI has searched the home of Joe
Biden now I call it a raid because when
they searched the home of Donald
surfaced and it looks like Hunter Biden
had access to classified information
somehow very strange indeed well I don't
know exactly what's going on or why some
people think it's that the Deep State's
trying to remove Joe Biden because he is
going to be running in 2024 so his team
says Administration that's what that's
what it's looking like we got a story
about a crying Chief of Staff saying
he's going to be with him when he runs
or something like that so maybe the Deep
State really does want to get rid of him
is the only way they can do it or I
actually think this may be a cover-up
we're learning now that the National
Archives were barred from telling the
world telling the American people that
they were searching the home of Biden
for these classified documents and in
fact found some now who would tell them
to do it it had to be Merrick Garland or
Joe Biden so it looks like the reason
they searched his house is because
they're working at his behest trying to
cover it up collect the documents and
stop the story from getting out and
that's exactly what they did and not the
midterms are over the story has gotten
out only because CBS News reported on it
so we'll talk about that Paul 's will
talk about whether or not he's going to
run we got Donald Trump declaring war on
the culture War apparently Trump's going
to make his key issues all about culture
War stuff and we've already started to
see it so this should be pretty
interesting and then we got Taiwan on
high alert
power goes out the LA Air at LAX LA
airport some people are concerned maybe
Cyber attack and then we have this
really crazy story it's it's kind of
e-drama celebrity gossipy but it's
interesting because it's about AI deep
fake porn and how like some twitch
streamers are crying because they're
they've been deep faked or whatever so
uh let's let's talk about how the future
is going to get crazy before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly click that join us
button and you can support not only this
show the videos I make over at
youtube.com timcast and timcast news the
website but you're helping with our
cultural Endeavors so we're going to be
setting up a physical space where it's
the coffee shop we have we've already
got the building the contractors coming
in we're going to start doing the
construction plus we have free damastan
it is nearing completion this would be
it's gonna be really exciting we're
gonna be launching a morning show a
skate show tons of really awesome stuff
and it's all thanks to you these things
take time plus of course we have the
fact checking non-profit which is
currently going through the filing
process and it's really it's it's
difficult to do these things because we
have to file in every single state it's
ridiculous but uh we're working on it
we're getting there and with your
support we're gonna get these things
done so thank you so much for being a
member don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all of this and
more is Samira Khan hi thank you so much
for having me very excited to be here so
uh who are you what do you do I'm an
independent journalist as of right now
but I used to work for RTE in DC I was
their Washington correspondent for a
little bit and uh yeah I've been in the
game for a little while and I find it
really interesting now I used to be in
the like Progressive left I was very
involved with the Bernie Sanders
campaign and then recently I think with
um the country moving I guess left uh I
guess I've taken more of like a Centrist
position and I've gotten pretty
anti-left so uh yeah that's my
background and anti-woke journalist is
that pretty much pretty much anti-woke
journalist but uh I used to focus more
so on foreign policy but I'm also like
Trump getting more so into the culture
War I find that really interesting and
it's the same thing right cultural War
they're they're also using in foreign
policy so on and so forth so same
spinning for the show so thanks for
thanks for joining us
hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com
oh okay all right I need a longer intro
yeah develop something I'm kind of in
your about Hannah Claire uh I'm Ian
Crossland got nothing to say too much
Samira we talked a little bit about your
last name Khan yeah maybe you come from
Genghis yeah I mean if he's my ancestor
that would be super based it's hardcore
yeah well good to see you people are
saying that when I was talking about in
the intro it glitched and like deleted
the part where I said Donald Trump was
running or something like this and going
after the culture War like a bunch like
four different superchargers just came
in said something some weird glitch
happened just to clarify Donald Trump is
running for president is what you said
well that he's declaring war on the
culture that's funny war I'm declaring
war on war or I should like it he didn't
say that yeah and I'm saying that he's
going to be directly addressing culture
War issues because he gets the biggest
Applause for it when he talks about the
culture where it's something I feel like
I can impact yeah like politics and
stuff I'm I feel like an outsider I can
offer advice and things like that from
the outside but the culture where I'm in
it you know we're in it yeah I mean it's
worked well for DeSantis and yunkin so
uh it's a smart decision on Trump's part
because I feel like one of the
criticisms that I've seen from his
supporters from Mega people is that he
hasn't gone hard enough on the culture
War stuff
but now that he's changing I think that
that's probably a good move for him yeah
it's worked for DeSantis so what do you
think Serge yo uh I'm at surge.com Joe's
running over this stupid sinus infection
so my voice sounds super weird yeah but
almost there done soon well let's jump
into this first store we got this from
The Daily Caller you may have seen the
news earlier today doj searches Biden's
Delaware home for a second time searches
just a search not right not a raid no
it's only a raid when you're going after
your political enemies right because Joe
Biden basically is the doj they're just
searching us uh his house so uh here's
what I want to point out we we had we
titled this his home's rated because
that's the say of Donald Trump they say
his home was rated right and it's like
Donald Trump was cooperating with them
letting them come in go through
everything that they went there twice
they went to the first time to put a
lock I said okay then come back break
the lock off take the documents and you
didn't cooperate and it's like he was
but the media does that thing yeah where
if Trump does it it's evil if Biden does
it it's no big deal no big deal isn't
his Daily Caller yeah calling it search
and that's my point when I'm reading the
post millennial and and even the
post-millennial called antifa domestic
terrorists protesters I'm like come on
oh my gosh Libby was here and I told her
I'm like Libby what are you doing she's
like I know I know and then there was
even even uh on timcast.com we we an
article was put up where it referred to
them as protests and I'm like they're
not they're being charged with domestic
terrorism so Joe Biden has the FBI go to
his house and say it was a planned
search why is the FBI searching the home
of the sitting president for illegally
held classified documents what is this
the fourth the fourth search of his
properties to be fair you know they've
had a 100 success rate so far they they
rated his first home definitely found
documents now have to check the beach
house and see if he left anything there
no they didn't find anything yeah I know
but like it's worked for them in the
past we can't trust that he hasn't I
mean Biden spends an enormous amount of
time at these two properties it's not
surprising I am surprised that they
didn't check it sooner right and I would
only object to the term search I think
possibly you could say it's a search
because I'm sure the Biden
Administration knew about it beforehand
whereas I don't think the same courtesy
was extended to Trump when they raided
Mar-A-Lago right yeah it is an act of
aggression the search is like hey just
so you know we're coming don't forget to
move that stuff in your garage yeah and
also uh before this before the entire
Trump debacle the FBI had very low trust
with the American people so they're
probably trying to make the FBI look
more credible again possibly that's a
good point could be one of their motives
for sure what was their reason for uh
going to his house anyway the Delaware
house did they have like a reasonable
cause there's probable cause for for
something being there or was it just
like they're calling it a search yeah I
think it's because he owns two
properties in Delaware one at Rehoboth
Beach and one in Wilmington the
Wilmington is where they found the
documents for so now they need to check
the other place where he spends a lot of
time one of the weekends where they were
searching his house he just went to his
other house in Delaware right like these
are places that he spends an enormous
amount of time so if he is doing
something he's not through documents it
makes sense that you would check both
properties it would be weird to leave
one off the list I feel like every
president would have classified
documents in their homes I mean and like
what is we talked about this one time
like what is a classified document is it
like a menu from a millionaire because
at one point those were classified I
don't know I mean it is weird they were
in his garage and whereas Trump had his
like stored in the appropriate way
but I mean I think it's cover-up yeah I
mean the spin is is interesting I think
that says a lot and I feel like this
headline in particular if you're not
aware that I keep saying this but
because he has two homes in Delaware
they're like they checked his Delaware
home there's nothing there it sort of
canceled out the headlines from a couple
weeks ago where he was like well we
checked his Delaware home and there were
documents I think here's what I'm
thinking
why did why why are they going after
Biden in these documents but Biden's
legal team I think his legal age are the
ones who actually informed the FBI that
had the documents whereas with Trump
they raid it's a legal issue imagine
this you're Joe Biden and you want to
dig up dirt on a political opponent your
principal political opponent or your
Merit Garland Garland basically Biden
says oh won't someone rid me of this
Trump and Merrick Garland goes I know
exactly what you're saying he then goes
and says let's go raid Trump's house
we're going to use the the documents you
know the the what was the the law what
is the National Archives actor whatever
that law is record keepings act or
something and they're going to use that
as the pretext to stop Trump from
running from Trump running in 2024 and
then Merrick Garland says but hold on if
this is going to work we got to make
sure Biden doesn't have the same problem
yeah he's got to be clean so then he
orders the search of Biden's property
not because he's targeting Biden because
he's helping Biden I see so trying to
make Trump look worse and if Biden gets
out of office and then they did the
raids it would announce like the Biden
name it would make him they'd be like
look you've got all the same things you
hypocrite so they're just getting out of
the way is that what you're saying they
when they re when they raided his house
the first time no one knew this was in
November they covered it up they they
they no one knew what happened okay so
I'm thinking you know we were talking
about this last week like why would why
would they go after buying is the Deep
State trying to remove him like ending
his 20 24 chances maybe it could be both
it could be this
they know Joe Biden can't run 2024 he's
not going to win yeah they also don't
want Trump to run and he will win what
do you do oh oh geez oh Biden you broke
the record keeping you can't run for
president now oh man that means Trump
can't run either oh and then if Trump
tries to run the butt hey look we even
stopped biding for money because we're
being fair interesting so he's like
there's sacrificial lamb yeah well I
mean there's also like a lot of
infighting going on with the Democrats
regarding Biden whether he should be the
one to run in 2024 or should they
replace him but after the midterms it
seemed like Biden's approval rating went
up so they stopped with the you know
anti-biting stuff for a while but I
don't know maybe this will change things
I mean he said he would announce after
Christmas right we're after Christmas he
has not announced and I think that can
only tell you that he wants to run yeah
and they don't want it's going to be a
progressive it might not be a little guy
who who could I think that's their
biggest issue they don't have a clear
front runner I know people have said
Newsome I know people say Kamala but
like Kamal is not likable's not like
well her her always have always been
lower than bidens and that's saying
something over at predict it you can buy
there's a it's a prediction Market thing
for those guys for those that don't know
you buy shares in in a concept so it's
like who will be the Democrats 2024
nominee and you can buy one share of
Kamala Harris yes for nine cents that
means if you buy a share for nine cents
and she does become the nominee you get
a dollar or like a dollar ten or
something like that and that's a
tremendous that's a ten to one return
right
but come on no sane person thinks she's
gonna be the nominee yeah I don't know
why people are buying shares in Kamal
hairs but here's the best part you can
buy no she won't be for 91 cents now
that means for every 91 cents you spend
when she invariably is not the the
nominee you get nine cents that sounds
like free money to me I'm not giving
Financial advice I'm just saying it's
kind of crazy where
there's no way
it's going to be really funny in 2024
when or 2023 who knows when they're like
I'm a Harris of the nominee and I'm just
like wow I could not did not see that
coming I gotta tell you man if someone
asked me to to make a large wager a
large sum of money
on whether or not Kamala Harris would be
the nominee I'd say no
this is not going to happen do you guys
think that in 2036 there will be a
United States
or that we will have a president that
will be able to have a pro you think
that will be structurally sound enough
yeah it'd be like four elections from
from coming or something it depends if
you know there's a Civil War coming or
not I wonder because I'm like we talk
about if we just sit here and wait is it
going to become like dude if we just sit
here and wait the world's gonna blow
itself up we have to like actively
change the system uh I can't I can't
wait for idiot a or idiot B to become
the next leader any anymore I'm
concerned that if we just if we just
play games and watch it like a TV show
that
the inevitable demise of the American
way is is around the corner I hate to
make a bet but I do think that they're
in 13 years that that feels far right
now but it's really not in the span of
time anyone who's in their 60s will
probably tell you that like 13 years can
go by really quickly I feel like
probably there's a country I would not
be surprised if the party system looks
different and that might be wishful
thinking on my part but I think it might
be a little bit yeah but I think that
there's so much like the the criticism
Democrats and the left-leaning media
always love yet Republicans is that
they're they're in fighting and they
don't get along but the same thing is
true for the left right and I think as
the youngest generation ages into being
a solid voter block you know they are
the most likely to cross lines on
tickets right if you ask them how they
feel about different issues it doesn't
all fall in one Camp so again wishful
thinking on my part but I don't think
the parties as we know them today
necessarily will be where be the same in
13 years I do think it's gonna get worse
it's going to get more Progressive on on
the Democrat side on the Republican side
too but they'll leave people yeah they
both will leave people behind like we
talk about this with like the shrinking
middle class like what if politics gives
way to a solid middle class and that
means ideologically not financially
block of Voters right the people who
don't feel like they have a home in the
Republican party or uh the I don't think
the two-party system is going to change
anytime soon I mean the Republicans and
Democrats they've collaborated and
colluded to make sure that never happens
um they've pretty much stopped
independent candidates from getting on
the debate stage I mean the last time
was Ross Perot that's never going to
happen again unless you know the
American people wake up I don't see that
happening anytime soon unless there is
some sort of Civil War so
I think the clearest sign would be if we
had more independent Governors I've not
thought that for a while because Oregon
ran an independent who got a fair amount
of votes she didn't win they let the the
Democrat went in uh but I do think that
like yes you're right it's just like
administratively it seems really hard to
imagine a non-to-party system but I just
don't think I mean it's not in our
constitution or anything it's not
awesome it's just the way things have
worked out right but I just think that
young voters are more likely to leave
the idea of like you have to be one or
the other behind
it's hard though because there are
states where you have to register with a
party to vote in that primer right and
that will be a difficult system to
change well according to polling I think
48 to 50 percent of Americans are
independent but then those Independents
end up voting either Republican or
Democrat when push comes because you
have to to participate in the primaries
you have to be in the party yeah and in
the general I'm talking about but as
more as as that gets left behind like if
we were to reverse States like there are
so many things that you have to do and
there are other states that don't want
that if we didn't have to identify in
the primaries I think you would see a
shift on the national platform again
wishful thinking on my part but or maybe
it has to be a top-down approach maybe
maybe it needs to start on the national
level it needs to start in the
presidential election for it to trickle
down yeah it'd be really interesting
yeah let me let me pull up this story
right here from The Daily Mail this is
why I think that the Joe Biden FBI raid
is actually a cover-up Daily Mail
reports what else are they hiding White
House claims transparency face even
White House claims of transparency face
even more scrutiny as it's revealed
National Archives was blocked from
releasing statement on classified
documents founded Biden's Think Tank the
Revelation came during question
questioning of archives general counsel
Gary Stern by top Republican James Comer
it raises questions over who stopped the
release from going public that is to say
just before the midterms when they
raided Biden's home and they they knew
he had these documents the National
Archives were barred by someone
it'd have to be either Biden or Merit
Garland they said do not make a
statement you are barred from doing so
that means when the midterms came
everybody
nobody had the opportunity to learn this
CBS News eventually reports it and
that's how we find out and now we're
actually getting some some information
as to what's going on now there there
there's more raids there's more searches
when it can affect the Democrats exactly
and this this says to me if it's Garland
or if it's Biden
they're covering it up well if someone
asked the National Archives to cover it
up for sure 100 if these guys were asked
not to report they were asked to come
and that means it was Biden or Garland
so maybe the Deep state is going after
Biden and he said no no don't let him
don't let anyone find out they're coming
after me I don't believe it because
they're all deep state they're all
establishment what likely happened is
they said we're going to use this
against Trump the documents but we got
to make sure you're clean before we make
that move so we're going to have the FBI
come in and search if they can find
anything and then we'll move forward
with Trump
and then they inadvertently found stuff
how the story went yeah when when did
they write Trump's house
when was that the fall was it November
months ago yeah
was it November it's an important
question was it before or after August
8th August 8th are they rated Trump's
house over the summer yeah so I I kind
of think they were like hey look this is
a big story and they're trying to say
maybe they do want Biden to run and they
were like if they go if if they go hard
on this Trump can't run for president
because of these documents we got to
make sure Biden doesn't have the same
problem
lo and behold he does
interesting I don't know what do you
think I think it's a malicious cover-up
a beneficial cover-up
going back to the Deep State thing what
other motives would the Deep State have
in getting rid of Biden aside from you
know he's not good for the Democrats I
can't think of any other motives because
he's doing exactly what they want them
and they don't need to get rid of him
they just need to be like okay Joe uh
we're gonna get somebody else I'm gonna
go okay yeah I just don't buy the whole
like Yeah The Deep state is I mean right
after him I think it's his health right
like if they could have run him again
they would have but like again this
sounds terrible but like he doesn't seem
healthy this is a continued issue like
the other day he just announced he's
extending uh covet orders and his office
said May 11th everyone knew it and then
he told reporters May 15th like he can't
keep basic important dates in mind right
he's a busy guy I guess he's got a lot
going on but like I think it's that
personally I think it's that he is not
healthy enough to run again and
therefore they have to replace him he
doesn't want wouldn't that happen
internally within the Democratic party
would they need this you know uh not if
he's gonna say oh I'm running I'm
running you cannot make me go on that
platform and say I'm not running I will
you know I'll see like if he digs his
heel to him what are they going to say
like I mean I think this has more to do
with making Trump look bad to be honest
in making Trump look bad I mean sorry
yeah um making him look better in
comparison to Trump oh he got rated too
but his wasn't that exactly his wasn't
that bad precisely
I think interesting yeah
I don't know man it's also confusing
because like we don't have the details
maybe they just screwed up they were
trying to cover this up they told the
National Archives not to say anything
but then CBS News got the story out now
they're scrambling yeah I don't know
maybe that's it maybe Joe Biden can't
run there was that uh former Clinton
aide said this is it for him it's going
to be the end and I'm I'm sorry I just
don't feel that way I feel like Joe
Biden could walk out in Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody in the face
not kidding not kidding Trump was right
when he was talking about that yeah for
real the current state of American
politics is
if you're in the if you're in the cult
you're in the cult yeah there was a
there's a really great tweet I saw and
it said
if you were on the left you are allowed
to deviate from leftist economic policy
without reprisal but you cannot deviate
on gender ideology race ideology and
that explains exactly what the left is
and it's like that's an interesting
point if you're woke but you say
something like I don't know if universal
healthcare could work nobody cares yeah
they just like oh that's interesting
right but if you are pro-universal
health care and you say hey that works
up to nonsense they call you right wing
yeah I mean it happens with minorities
too you saw when um all of the Muslims
in Dearborn protested against the
sexualization of children they called
them terrorists you know these are the
same Muslims that they're left pretended
to defend during the war on terror Etc
now they're calling them literal
terrorists because you know they're
against Folk so I heard a story where it
was like apparently some woman was at a
diversity training and they said you
know what's say your name in pronouns
said oh no thank you I'm not religious
and then people started chuckling and
then everyone refused to give pronouns
and I'm like yeah maybe that happened it
does kind of sound like a and then
everyone clapped kind of story you know
because I don't I don't see people as uh
willing to stand up like I said Joe
Biden could walk on a Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody and they'd still vote for
him yeah so I'm not I'm not convinced
that the average person who's aware of
what's going on with the corruption the
communism whatever you want to call it
is willing to actually stand up and say
anything because the the story that
breaks my heart we heard the other day
from Matt Strickland is that he defies
these lockdown orders he wins in court
he wins the political battle he was
right the whole time and he said people
call him and say what you did was great
how can I help you and he's like and he
says do what I did and go oh no no I
couldn't do that you know they'll come
after me and that that's how it feels
too many people are just like no no no
no don't look at me I'm gonna stay right
here where it's easy yeah they think
it'll will pass eventually but it's only
going to get worse we've seen this
throughout history
I mean the gender pronoun thing I've
made jokes saying like on Twitter saying
yeah there's going to be Republicans
with pronouns in their bios in 10 years
we'll see oh yeah yeah of course the
joke I made is that the Democratic party
is going to be hive mind Singularity pod
people versus transgender Communists and
that'll be the Republican party and you
know the Democrats will be the hive mind
AI people yeah and they'll be like hive
mind rights and they'll start arguing
that once you join the collective you
know you have a right like if a
non-citizen becomes part of the
collective they retain their voting
power because the collective is one one
unit or something like that then they're
going to be like we need a new system of
voting because ranked Choice voting
doesn't work anymore they're going to be
on like double bypass rank Choice
inversion voting where you know who you
vote for the third time gets counted
against you and some weird you know
anybody can vote and then they're going
to be like well he's in the hive now so
he's we are one and that means you know
he can he can vote and there's one vote
and we vote for Joe Biden again
Whoever has the best most feeling is the
one that would decide what the hive does
yeah so in order to vote in the future
you walk into a room close your eyes and
think real hard then we record it trust
us we're getting the account right we we
know yeah we go we got your vote yeah
and then they leave and it's like oh I
wonder you know who's gonna win and
they're like 99.9 Joe Biden you know I
don't think that the gender stuff is
just going to get worse you said earlier
like Chloe Cole gives me a lot of
inspiration I'm not sure if you're
familiar with her story she's like uh
she might be 19 at this point but she
had underwent uh surgery like
transgender surgery and had her double
mastectomy her breasts removed when she
was like 13 or 14 I don't want to get
the numbers wrong um but it's right
around that age I think it's 15 15 15.
and then realized what the
pharmaceutical companies were doing to
her or or enabling her to do to herself
for profit and uh came out and started
speaking out against it and she's
immensely popular right now with all
sorts of people from all ages so I think
we went through a horrible period in the
last six years of pharmaceutical
overreach in my opinion yeah and and
digging into these kids for money
um but if you look at Europe and you see
how overly woke they are at you can tell
that the trajectory of the U.S is going
to follow that of Europe
right you know they've all had these
debates the bathroom debates and
everything and that their solution for
example for the bathroom thing is that
you know we're going to have unisex
bathrooms so I mean that's just one
example but if you want to see the
future of the U.S in terms of wokism and
and leftist ideology you look to
Scandinavia and Western Europe so in
California yeah true apparently
California is always five years ahead of
the rest of the United States yeah I saw
I covered this story a few years ago it
was talking about something related to
their weird policies and it said
historically the policies Implement
there make their way to the rest of the
country within five years so if you want
to figure out where things are going to
be in five years Look at California and
if you do well then any sane person is
going to get out of the city go to the
middle of nowhere and get some chickens
because otherwise you're gonna be
walking around New York gonna walk
around DC and there's going to be human
feces all over the streets and there
probably already are it's just that in
San Francisco it's way way worse in
Sacramento it's worse but that's that's
coming to a neighborhood near you
well and I would assume all the
migration that happened during the covid
lockdowns is going to influence that
right have you ever seen these maps of
like how people migrated and a lot of
them left California and left went to
States you wouldn't have predicted like
we always talk about this potentially
right they they bring their ideology and
their policies with them right they're
frustrated by what's happening in their
state but not by everything they like
just like one policy but they're going
to keep most of the others
yep naturally the country is just going
to move more left
in terms of socio-cultural I'm not I'm
not so convinced really uh yeah I think
it's going to be so we started seeing
this shift with Gen Z because leftists
don't have kids they have yours but that
that only goes so far when you start
getting a pushback in the culture war
and I think mathematically it doesn't
matter whether or not they indoctrinate
kids I don't I think that all that
matters is the birth rate if
conservatives have even one kid per
family and Democrats have none kids per
family then the future even though will
be a population reduction will be way
more conservative and then people argue
yeah but the the woke are trying to
indoctrinate those kids yes but they
don't exist in large enough numbers so
if there's two leftist teachers trying
to indoctrinate your indoctrinate your
child then as they get older they're
dying off maybe they convert 10 maybe
let's say they convert 40 percent of all
conservative children into woke that
still means they are not replacing their
own ideological selves right and so over
long enough period like what's the
conversion rate you think for a
conservative kid into a woke kid I don't
think it's a particular percent it's
probably very low yeah you grow up in it
you grow up in a religious conservative
family you probably become slightly
libertarian as you get older but you're
still going to be somewhat conservative
people go through phases too I was I
went through like a real uh
post-modernist you can be whatever you
believe you are phase in my 20s and then
I realized the reality starts sitting
and I realize oh people will starve if
we don't get resources from point A to
point B you know the whole I believe is
not it's not good enough you know
reality it will slap you in the face
metaphorically if you just play them I
am what I think I am game yeah I think
you were making a point about
Generations right so if Generation Z if
you're seeing like a conservative turn
usually the next generation will be more
woke right so if you see backlash in a
certain no no no no no no you don't
think so uh research shows that every
generation starts skewing further and
further left but gen Z was the first
time in 100 years it actually ticked
back towards conservative because
something else I read um baby boomers
they were for there for that time period
they were woke you know they were
against the Vietnam War and Etc but then
Generation X that was the backlash
generation but uh well like they're all
more Progressive yeah on everything like
Boomers were resistant to gay marriage
gen xers were more accepting of it
Millennials were completely accepting of
it and then resulting in a favorable
cultural environment to make to legalize
or I should say to codify not even
codify to rule in the Supreme Court that
it just is yeah and I think it went from
20 in the 90s to like 80 percent now I
mean it's considered one of the fastest
shifting cultural issues of all time
crazy I wonder how alpha is going to
turn out I mean if Zoomers are this way
then it's not about how they turn out
it's about who has the kids oh yeah
conservatives have more kids than
liberals and Liberals are now more
likely to sterilize and more likely to
abort their children so it's only a
matter of time I don't you know people
talk about all the politics and they're
like yeah but they're in schools and
they're indoctrinating and I'm just like
doesn't matter math you're not going to
change it like over a long enough period
of time it's like saying
you know you go you go to a casino
because I was making the I said if I was
going to make a bet on you know Kamala
Harris people who are like Tim's got a
gambling problem because I always do the
gambling analogy but if you go to a
casino the house has an edge like how is
it that you can play all these games The
House Always Wins because in blackjack
they have a 0.5 percent higher chance of
winning that that means you can win a
million dollars it doesn't matter over
the year they win point five percent of
all of those bets statistically and
that's all that matters and that's what
I'm talking about with wokeness they can
do whatever they want they can
indoctrinate this kid and this kid they
can get Greta tunberg up on the big TV
but over a long enough period of time
their attrition rate is just too high if
they want to abort their kids and stare
look a board in their kids was one thing
right the uh leftists Liberals are
substantially more likely to get
abortions than Christians can serve it
as Etc and that right there is a hard
mathematical fact which is why many
people were saying for a while it
features Muslim because Muslims have
even more kids than Christians and
that's that's that's that's the number
that's all that matters however now
Liberals are sterilizing their kids so
that means it's almost like a
retroactive removal removal from future
Gene pools basically if you go back to
the 1990s and check abortion rates
you're going to be like we can do the
math liberals were aborting at this rate
conservatives at this rate you're going
to see more conservatives guess what we
are conservatives are having more kids
Liberals are having less kids why
because Liberals are aborting their
babies so in the early 2000s
conservatives were having I think it's
like 2.05 kids on average and Liberals
are having like 1.73 now what do we see
gen Z slightly more conservative in some
areas but fairly comparable to
Millennials now here's what they didn't
track for
when they were talking about abortion or
they weren't talking about abortion they
said do do liberals have kids do
conservative have kids and and the
answer was conservatives have more why
they were probably banging at the same
rate or similar rates but liberals were
having abortions reducing that number
now end the fact that those kids from
the 2000s who are 23 today have a higher
likelihood of being sterilized being uh
chemically castrated or transitioning or
just outright not wanting to have kids
as productive ideology so you add that
and now those people will not have
children so the the birth rate on the
left is going to go down further
personally I'm not a fan of any of that
stuff I think people should have
families and they'll enjoy it but if the
left doesn't want to have kids that's
the future that they've built yeah there
it is right it makes sense makes sense I
didn't know any of that actually it
assumes um you know a stable system
peaceful system
um it doesn't well because slavery is
real too like human slavery if if a
liberal Society were to go full militant
and just start killing and enslaving
children
um then they then they would be like
does you know then that would have won
you tell me you're telling me that you
think that if the the the circumstances
in the United States become
substantially more arduous
that it's then liberals will do better
no I think the ideology is destined for
failure that personal ideology of
cutting up kids and making them take
their penis off when they're 12 like
that's not gonna work and I'm not
species and I'm not saying that's like
in in massive numbers in the millions
it's in the thousands maybe even tens of
thousands and it may be reversing
because of what we're saying with people
like Chloe Cole but what I'm saying is
if you make a an easy comfortable system
you will start seeing more liberals and
leftists but they want gluttony more
than conservatives want gluttony that
many conservatives do so they abort and
sterilize their kids
but then you give them hardship
and conservatives are substantially more
likely to survive that hardship because
of meritocracy personal responsibility
and things like that so if it does
become a dictatorship all that means is
more liberals will struggle to succeed
maybe I was just secretives will succeed
I was thinking of the Soviet Union
because that was a real liberal Uprising
they were all like wacky radical
leftists and uh they just killed
everyone else and took control
physically so enforced the ideology if
not for other countries around Earth and
and what one out in the end was I
wouldn't call it yeah it was oligarchy
yeah but then that period of the 90s
where you know oligarchs ruled
everything you know they liked Western
liberalism but now there's backlash
right and now they want to revive the
Soviet Union in Russia I mean Stalin is
the most popular figure in Russia and
they yeah literally want to go back to
the Soviet Union yeah how is that
happening who wants that and what do
they want exactly well I mean if you
look at polling data Western polling
data Stalin is the number one you know
most popular figure and if you talk to
Russians these days you know they want
they want to go back to the days of the
Soviet Union because that period of the
90s was just so horrible for the Russian
people and then Putin changed everything
when he came in in 2000 you know Russia
was declining economy was really bad and
then you know slowly he
re-industrialized and then changed the
economy for the better and now you know
Putin has been very good for the Russian
people well and maybe you can speak to
this but don't most Russian people not
want what modern Western values are
right and no they don't so I mean they
they admire the West because of you know
Hollywood and everything of Western yeah
because of the cultural power that the
West has but they are completely against
Western liberal values in fact there was
a bill that was just passed where they
expanded the anti-lgbt law that they had
and this was you know across the board
every party agreed with that they were
like no we're not going to have this uh
LGBT gender ideology propaganda in
Russia you know that's the the West so
it's hardening them even more so I saw
an interview with Putin a bunch of
college kids and they were like you
could see they wanted him to be like yes
we are now a liberal democracy but he
wasn't he was staying hard in there yeah
and then uh they were like what should
we what uh senior or whatever they
called him Putin what should I do as a
man in Russia and Putin was like you
should learn to cook and he was like
haha everyone laughs he's like no as a
real man a Russian man there's like this
misogynist energy behind it all and that
that stood out to me that there's this
intense like misogyny in the Russian and
that and that guy and that guy and Putin
still was like no you should learn to
cook because the economy is about to go
to crap but that's what he was saying
it's a very Macho culture I mean I've
been to Moscow um and then you see it in
the UFC as well look at how all of the
Russian Fighters and everything you know
they're doing really really well they're
dominating the MMA world and that's part
of their culture you know men should be
men and women should be women you know
they women Embrace their femininity they
don't reject it and they don't try to be
more masculine like you know it's uh it
is here when you were saying that they
want to bring back people want to bring
that Soviet Union do they want do they
know what they want or is it just that
they want something better than what
they have and they're like well it's
actually
um uh older Russians that experience the
Soviet Union that wanted back the most
this is it's interesting because it's
the opposite right because in the U.S
you have young Millennials that are more
socialist and then the older people here
uh they're like anti-socialist
anti-communist but in Russia younger
people they're more into you know
liberal values but then the older people
who experience communism they want the
Soviet Union back so it's like the
complete opposite it's just derived
through polls and things or polls yeah
mostly through polls and then you know
um I I don't necessarily go with like
lived experiences but that was my
experience in Russia as well how long
did you I was there for a month you know
I was there for work but uh it was a uh
enlightening experience because it
killed whatever progressivism and
leftism I had in me because it was a
totally different culture I'd never
really gone elsewhere aside from you
know like Western Europe so
um it's a very anti-progressive
anti-woke culture I mean it's pretty
much built in
it's very interesting going to Russia
you should have killed the wokism out of
you or like whatever progressivism I had
inside of me you know
um from you know like the Bernie days it
was just completely gone
um I became less I became more
Politically Incorrect you know but see
the thing with Bernie he wasn't uh he
wasn't woke yeah it wasn't the same
thing yeah he did that interview that
famous interviewer was like you got to
secure the borders you could have you
got to secure the bonus yeah and then um
they the world socialist website call
them a nationalist capitalist yeah
because he wanted to shut the borders
down and these people are Global
socialists yeah and then he changed his
whole shtick right in 2020 and that's
why I think he lost the primary because
you know he went full on the Ed pole and
the uh gender ideology and all that
stuff so it's like
yeah that's why he destroyed himself but
yeah sorry it sounded like a weirdo yeah
the regular people were like I don't
know what that's all about this guy's
crazy it went from unite the working
class to Identity politics in 2020.
that's how they do it that's how they
did with Occupy Wall Street they did
with Bernie Sanders yeah I feel like we
didn't mention it but it would be remiss
not to point out that universities are
also not quite as popular as they were
like you hear this all the time people
say you send your kid to University and
they move more left even if they were
raised in a conservative family but
studies are show I mean especially with
kovid we saw so many people opt not to
return to college and feel like it
wasn't worth it people are aware of how
much of a financial burden it is well
even Elon Musk is saying college is
useless yeah you know we'll want to work
at Tesla you don't need to have a
bachelor's degree right and this is more
and more also like if I'm going to take
on however much amount of debt to not
make that much money versus someone who
goes into a trade or any other thing who
gets a head start who's making more
money than you are even after your
four-year degree it doesn't make any
sense uh the national Clearinghouse put
out this study release from enrollment
from last year and they found that the
enrollment was down across the board
master's degrees any program definitely
down among undergraduates but it's uh
significantly down among women for the
first time in a really long time which I
find interesting yeah we've known for a
while that men are declining fewer men
are enrolling in college than women but
now just in the last year I can't say
it's a full-on trend but you saw twice
as many women didn't return to college
didn't enroll for the first time I
wonder what it is you know with like uh
Elon Musk and many others I think Peter
Thiel talked about how college is
useless is we often said or the belief
was the reason men weren't going to
school going to college was because they
were lazy or they were living in their
parents basements and things like that
I'm wondering if dudes just figured it
out yeah I think they do men and women
are continually under the social
pressure where they're like you've got
to go to school and get a degree so you
can be a CEO because of patriarchy and
you have to prove yourself you have to
prove that you are just as good as all
them in your class by getting the degree
whereas men don't necessarily feel that
same kind of pressure and they are
capable of doing all kinds of things not
that women aren't but they're well I'll
just pursue this thing over here I also
think traditional learning environments
aren't suited for most men right like
it's not typical I mean we didn't do
this for a long time to have you also
employers are also saying that college
graduates are not prepared adequately
for you know working and everything yeah
it's useless it's just a holding pattern
I mean at one point academics like
universities and schools they really
were sort of interesting places they
prepared you to work but I don't think
that's true more I mean I went to a four
University and I was grateful for the
experience but I knew so many people who
enrolled in Master's programs because
they didn't want to be adults yet yeah
and they also say that college graduates
lack critical thinking skills because
they're taught to memorize I mean that's
the American education system especially
in college you're not rewarded for
thinking critically and analytically I
want to talk to you guys about uh that
TV show The Last of Us have you guys
seen it no no never have you guys ever
played the video game negative so uh
it's it's a video game that came out I
think it's like 10 years old the show is
huge right now it's on episode three
they've already renewed it for second
season it's got Pedro Pascal in it I
think his name is and it's really good
three episodes in what's it about uh
cordyceps the fungus that takes over
insects bodies and turns them into
zombies mutates to infect humans Society
collapses fungus it's this thing that
looks like a mushroom make people look
like mushrooms yeah type of mushrooms
according to Paul stamets the world
leading Mycologist cordyceps do not eat
humans right I believe that's the point
of the show shows that it mutates and
does and then basically the world
collapses but the reason I want to talk
to you about this third episode is
particularly culturally relevant as it
pertains to medically assisted medical
assistance and death and dying or
whatever they call it and the show is
about a post-apocalyptic gay
relationship and so the reason I brought
up is we're just talking about the
difference between men and women in
college and it got me thinking about
this so I like there's an interesting
Dynamic that I was talking about earlier
where you've got all these people saying
this is one of the best TV shows ever
made because it depicts a prepper the
world ends three years later he's all
he's all alone for three years he meets
a guy and then becomes gay I guess
because he wasn't before and then it
depicts spoiler alerts I'll try to avoid
most heavy spoilers if you haven't seen
the show but it depicts this like story
of them living together in the
apocalypse and then in the end the
controversy being generated around it is
that his uh one guy one guy's like sick
and they're old and there's no doctors
so he's like I want you to poison me and
I'll die and then the other guy is like
I won't do it that's wrong and he's like
it's my life it's my choice and this is
how I'm going to go out and then he's
like okay fine and then I already warned
you guys major major spoil alert like
it's in all over the news and I I I'm
gonna spoil it because you know it's and
I've already spoiled part of it but it's
because like the medical assistance and
dying thing going on in Canada the dude
then basically crushes up a bunch of
pills puts it in a bottle of wine and
then tricks the guy and poisons himself
along with the guy and then he says it's
the most objectively it's the most
romantic thing ever done and so you have
these two guys committing suicide
together and they're glorifying it
glorifying it and then people are coming
out now saying it's like the greatest
episode of TV ever made and stuff like
that and I'm like I gotta be honest it
was good it was I mean it's a modern
take on Romeo and Juliet well the one
thing I wanted to bring up is the
yeah sorry like the gay relationship
elicits no emotion in me at all it just
it just really doesn't and then I'm I'm
not trying to be a dick to gay people
like by all means if you like dudes do
your thing I got no I got no beef but
what I'm hearing in the media is that
it's like it's so romantic these two
guys are like they love each other so
much the guy decided if you die I'm
gonna die with you and they both poison
themselves and I'm just like the
glorification of suicide that's scary
and then calling it romantic and I'm
just like I wouldn't find it romantic
it's tragic in Romeo and Juliet it's
it's tragedy it's not romance but what
we're seeing now is culturally
medical assistance and dying is being
they're pushing it it's more favorable
in Europe they're doing it yeah in
Canada they're doing it we had those
stories where like the veteran calls and
he's like I need help and they're like
have you considered dying and now we get
a TV show that I'm not it's not like
it's a young girl you know like a 20
year old being like I've decided to die
and then dying or like a suicide because
that's that's depicted in shows all the
time it's like two guys who are alive
and one guy's saying you know what
today's my last day because I've chosen
it and then he's like let's go for it
and then they call it romantic and there
it's all heartwarming I don't know man I
just feel like
whether it's intentional or not this is
what we're going to start seeing in the
future yeah we already singing at Canada
we're already seeing it in Europe how
long until you think it comes to the
United States 10 years suicide booths
like in Futurama I mean it's assisted
suicide is legal in Washington and
Oregon already it's all right there it
is there's it's not a question I mean
there's this documentary called how to
die in Oregon I probably referenced it a
million times but this is one of the
things that happens a man is on you know
State Health Care and he has a tumor and
the state won't pay for his treatment
it's too expensive it's beyond what he's
permitted but they will pay for his
assisted suicide that's what they're
doing in Canada yeah it's I mean but
this movie came out easily 10 years ago
I mean this is something that we already
had and we're just seeing the effects
play out all the time I think what's
weird about this show having never seen
it is like it goes against what we might
say is like the glorification of like
the West right so like I've been
watching the show Yellowstone and like
all the other ones and like there is a
fight to survive right like if you're in
a post-apocalyptic world I don't really
know maybe you don't feel like there's
anything worth left living for but like
at our core I think people want stories
where it's like but I push through
anyways because it was worth it because
ultimately we are like glorious in our
in our uh Victory so this was a
component of the episode like basically
and again spoiler alerts in the end the
main character goes to the house because
they were friends and then he's like
where is he and there's a note and the
guy writes this letter saying I used to
hate everybody and I hated everything
but then I realized I learned that there
actually was one person worth saving and
that's what I did I saved him I give to
you all my equipment use it to save
those you love blah blah blah and I'm
just like yo this at this show I I I'm
wondering if it's like
they're trying it's wokeness yeah that
they're having two they're two bearded
Burly looking dudes in a relationship
and I felt like
it just doesn't resonate I do not feel
this man's love I do not I felt nothing
from it in the previous episode Joel's
significant other tests sacrifices
herself she gets bit to save them and
blows herself up that I felt and then
what I did feel in the end of the
episode is when he writes the guys like
use my equipments to save to save tests
or to protect her but she's already dead
and so that was like brutal like all of
a sudden you're in this post-apocalyptic
world you have nothing no gas no cars
he's like they're showing like a plane
crash it's like we used to be able to
fly we can't anymore and then this guy
who's a prepper has all of this amazing
stuff and he's like it's yours now use
it to protect Tess and she's already
dead yeah that was brutal I feel like
this wokeness
I don't know what is this is this like
Democrat Prime predominant predominantly
females going oh they love each other
and then it's like moderate dudes just
being like yeah sure I guess you know I
don't know what do you guys think I
didn't see it but I think when two
actors are uh doing a love scene if they
actually love each other as people it it
reads in the movie like in the notebook
uh Ryan Gosling and the girl uh I can't
even remember that girl's name but it
was like just it's a gut-wrenching movie
I don't know if you guys have seen it
before I cried when I saw the movie but
they actually fell in love while they
were shooting that if these dudes in The
Last of Us don't actually have emotions
for each other but they're just playing
the character of a gay lover it's gonna
be you're gonna hear about it the the
lizard brain's gonna be like
you're like the seal in you is gonna
clap but no one it's not real it's the
idea of it that they love but if there's
no love there then there's no love there
I mean I just felt like I was watching
this show and you're supposed to be sad
that these two people are in love with
each other and they're dying and I'm
like
I don't see it I don't see it I don't
feel it it doesn't if it was if it was a
woman I would have understood yeah or
what if they were like Father and Son
yeah
yeah it's like a guy and his kid and his
kid gets bit and he has to kill him
you'd be like oh man like so brutal or
It's the dad who like throws the cat of
the way and gets a bit that was
literally the the second the second
episode of Tess who is the woman
significant other for Joel they're
fighting these things and then she's
like let's go and then she's in there
they go to this place and the zombies
find out or something and then he like
the kids like she's infected and then
he's like show me and she he sees the
bite and he's like no and then she's
like get out of here and she sacrifices
herself and it's brutal to watch yeah
but yeah I was like if this episode was
like a guy and he he meets some like
teenage kid and then over the next five
six years he's teaching the kid how to
shoot and he's teaching the kid how to
prep and survive and then it ended with
him like throwing the cat out of the way
and then getting bit on the arm and the
kid has to shoot him and he's crying
would have been the most brutal episode
ever but two adult Burly bearded men I
am not trying to be a dick I don't care
if that's your thing that's your thing I
just I don't feel like that resonates I
don't see Brokeback Mountain I did not I
didn't either you guys see that was it
good I heard it was phenomenal uh
I have no I mean the one from 2005. you
know Jake Gyllenhaal I mean I didn't
think it was that great I thought it was
just a cultural message I think a guess
that I had is that they actually started
to have emotional feelings I'd like to
ask Jake if it happened but he killed
himself short like not that long after
like I think he was like doing a lot of
drugs really was like am I gay what's
wrong with me and then you know it gets
I know actor in college that did a gay a
play where he was gay and the other
actor was gay and was just loving making
out with him on stage and then my buddy
hung himself no wow many like 20 years
later but he hung himself and it's like
that he told me at one point that play
still sticks with me in the back of my
mind like as a form of almost like pros
like he was felt like prostituted into
it for the role because it was a great
role wow um anyway it's a little off
base yeah but it's not fake like when
you're doing these scenes you actually
do begin to feel these things and if
these actors were on guard from that uh
it won't play you'll know that in the
scene you won't feel it because they're
guarded from it
just the danger of being an actor one of
the dangers of being an actor God you
know loved Heath Ledger what that guy
went through I don't know man the thing
about the the medical assisted suicide
to go back to that point yeah is that if
we're talking about somebody who's
bedridden the and and have has no way to
pay their bills and the doctor's like
you've got three weeks left and they're
just like well you know I'm in agony and
pain and the morphine's not cutting it
anymore like what do you guys think so
my question is do you think that
depression eventually will be used as
like a acceptable I guess justification
for doing this for going through this
process I think that just happened if I
I should pull the story really quickly
but there is a uh there was a girl in so
if you could improve you're depressed
then she will kill yourself she was it's
in Europe I believe I'll look it up in a
second but there was a girl who survived
Belgium you're right Belgium she um she
was going on a class trip she was in an
airport and the airport was in bombing
and she apparently developed really
serious post-traumatic stress syndrome
and had all kinds of issues use
hospitalizah attempted suicide and
eventually was granted permission to go
through assisted suicide because she
said her Depression was so crippling she
could never get over it and this girl
was like what 18 19. I mean she was
young she's young so you know what's the
limit you know are they going to go I'm
not saying I agree with that I just no
no I'm just saying in general like
what's the limit of ADHD is that gonna
be accepted I mean I mean it's like a
weird form of eugenics I feel like yeah
right we're just eliminating sounds like
you can't hack it I guess acne I mean I
don't know like I kind of am
oh I don't really care about the
assisted suicide stuff I don't know my
crate I never have I'm like if you want
to kill yourself kill yourself who cares
like we've got so many humans because
everybody always regrets it they don't
actually want to do it that's what we
were talking the other day everybody who
jumped off the Golden Gate Bridge and
survived said the first thing that
happened was they regretted doing it
yeah so you have these people who are
feeling fear or Panic they're scared
they're in pain and they think it's the
only way to make it stop
and they regret it and so the goal is to
help them not do that because it's the
wrong thing like I knew a guy like the
guy was just telling you guys about he
wanted to die so he killed himself no
one could stop him but then in another
instance I know a girl that tried to
kill herself a couple times and then she
didn't and now she's got a family so and
I assure you your friend was if he was
alive today he'd be like I'm sure glad
that didn't happen yeah I think so he
was like something Horrible's coming man
he was like really it was like 27 no it
was 2019 when he killed himself it was
like 2015 he told me like something
bad's happened he left New York City
he's like something bad's coming dude he
was like the best actor I knew too but
do you feel like because he felt like
something bad was happening it he should
have been able to kill himself right
like if you were in a position to have
influence over it which of course you
weren't it's a horrible thing to ask but
like
with with assisted suicide or what they
often refer to as euthanasia right like
euthanasia you feel like you're putting
someone out of their misery and that's
why it starts with these conversations
about people who are in very serious
organ failure they have very serious
cancers they will not survive and so is
it is it a higher quality of life to let
them choose when to end the problem the
problem is if you open the door to
medically assisted suicide it will
expand exactly exactly I'm a concern
that some people if they want to die and
you don't let them that they will lash
out and start ruining other people's
lives and making the world a worse place
but that's on the individual level I
think that the collective consequences
of you know starting this whole like
medically assisted suicide trend is is
much worse and
um than you know the individual
consequences of you know one person
lashing out in their own Community
versus you know starting this Global
Trend right you know it also like it
also reduces the friction in doing so
it's very difficult to do it it's not as
easy as everyone thinks it is to just
you know go ahead and do it those people
get drunk people like do a bunch of
drugs before they do it they don't just
you know if you make it a nice hospital
setting with doctors like helping you do
it and your family surrounding you
holding your hand saying it's a good
thing that's crazy exactly it makes it
way easier yeah more romantic right yeah
exactly it sure does seem like they
don't want a lot of people I'm thinking
of apop cellular apoptosis when you've
got cells in your body they they
pre-program themselves to die like some
cells when they're no longer needed or
they're causing damage to the system
because they're taking too many
resources they will kill themselves on
purpose to make the body healthier and I
I think humans are fractally doing that
similar thing I mean there are cultures
right where that's the expectation for
people who are too old or too sick
they're supposed to like remove
themselves from the society but like et
cetera I don't know that that is
something that I would personally be
okay with it would be really difficult
for me to accept that people are uh
pointing out that in the beginning of
the show people commented that a portion
got dropped or deleted like it just I
was talking about Biden getting ready it
was gone and we've had so many of these
kind of things happen that I don't
believe they can be coincidences because
it's just it happens a lot so someone
just super chatted that they just
started watching and in the beginning
the intro was cut like you can't
actually hear me talk about what
happened with Biden but we talk about
them again and again and again
throughout this show I want to tell
everybody what happened with turning
point us X I'm not sure we ever actually
talked about it but when we went live
with Turning Point USA you may have
noticed we were late
we weren't late actually we were on time
the stream started right on time and
then what happened Serge remember that
you guys were like it says we're live
but we're not coming up right right yeah
yeah it was it was live to us and it's
live in my feeds and but nobody could
see it they were like where's the show
the show's delayed right and then I got
messages and they were like people were
telling me after the show they were like
hey the show didn't go up for like 10
minutes but we were live streaming on
our end everything was going through and
I'm wondering if you know we had Charlie
Kirk we had Bannon we had James Lindsay
we had lucratkowski you and me I'm
wondering if the people at YouTube were
like boss what do we do hmm pool Bannon
Kirk lukerkowski Ian James are on stage
in a massive stadium with thousands of
seats and they're gonna talk at this
massive convention
what do we do with this and then they
were like holding pattern and then they
watched us and they were like okay
they're gonna holding pattern let me get
confirmation from the boss as to what to
do and they were like Let It Go Let It
Go I'm wondering if any if anyone else
did something like this like these kind
of that that exact conversation were to
happen I'd imagine they would have
gotten a strike and they've gotten
banned but I wonder if YouTube was
scared like we cannot defend against a
lawsuit from from turning point from
Steve Bannon and from from Tim Poole all
at the same time over this and because
they're on stage at the at this massive
Convention Center the the pr damage from
taking the show down would be so massive
but so that's that's a possibility Elon
Musk needs to buy YouTube yeah good luck
but the reason I think it's it's
possible it's possible that they've got
their thumb on the scale is because
you guys who watch the show consistently
know this there was one episode where
Luke started talking about the CIA and
then the stream cut off wow yep dropped
off like Luke made some specific points
and then stream just stops and then
kicks back in a few seconds later and
people are like what did Luke just say
what was he saying and that's literally
what happens now and it happens a lot
maybe maybe it's just like a random
glitch that happens yeah Perhaps Perhaps
it could be that would happens a lot but
it doesn't happen during like we're
talking about a TV show it doesn't
happen we're talking about quantumania
or Thanos or anything like that it's own
specific topics only when we're like the
intelligence agencies are doing this
thing and drop but it could happen at
other times we just wouldn't know
because no one would say anything
because we weren't talking about
anything right and also I'd also see
that the drop frames would tell me that
like we're dropping frames in like a
huge number it would tell me that it's
not doing that but behind the scenes at
mines I would tell you that don't don't
assume malfeasance if there's technical
glitches it's very easily like AWS is
acting up your servers are you know I
don't they're transferring data from one
server to another I'm done believing
it's all just a mistake yeah right we've
been talking about censorship and big
tech for seven eight years now or long I
mean longer actually maybe even nine
years Luke was getting demonetized
before anyone knew what the word was
someone was manually going check this
out we all know what it means to be
demonetized on YouTube these days you
got a little dollar sign icon on your
video you go in one day it's yellow and
it says you know
ads Limited
when Luke from we are change was making
videos this is back in like 2011 I'm
hanging out with him and then one day
he's like dude my ads are turned off
again and in his account the little
green icon it was a circle back then is
greyed out he'd have to go back in the
video and activate it again then he'd
come back later and they'd all be gray
again and he'd go in and turn them on
turn them on turn them on turn them on
because there was no formal
demonetization process yeah someone at
Google or YouTube was manually axing his
account and taking ads off of each
individual video so we know that was
happening then then they created the
system to automate it now we have this
I look I I went and hung out at the
offices of Ustream back in the day do
you guys remember that we used to stream
on that yeah yeah with the letter U
that's where Joe Rogan started streaming
wasn't it he said you don't know
and they had guys sitting at a table
with a bunch of computers computers and
on the monitors there would be like 50
live streams all going at once and they
would and I'm like what is this and
they're like we basically just watch all
of it and if someone looks like they're
becoming a problem we move them over
into this panel on the left and then
basically they they they they look for
people who are about to break the rules
or they think might break the rules take
them from the main grid and put them in
the select box and then if that person
takes their shirt off or does something
they nuke it right away take the stream
right down yeah I know YouTube has that
right YouTube has to have way more
sophisticated tools than that yeah they
probably have ai watching language I
wouldn't even be surprised if they have
ai reading voice Cadence so if you start
to get agitated it can tell yep and
that's so the trick is to just deliver
horrible messages
don't move your eyebrows yeah very very
well I think they have humans who watch
and for a show like this as big as it is
I'm willing to bet that there's like 10
shows and they have like one guy who's
watching all at the same time or more
importantly I'm willing to bet for a
show this big they have one guy who's
hired to watch the show at least one guy
probably one person and they're like
because your show Rogan show and a few
others yeah any big live streams Joe's
not on YouTube anymore oh right true
yeah but uh but all the big live streams
I suppose I can only say don't I agree
with you don't believe that nothing is
going on but just don't believe anything
about it don't believe that it's people
there twisting knobs don't believe that
it's the data getting corrupted like
there's no way to know so there's no
point in coming in with a strong belief
on it but I would like to know I would
say it seems highly probable that is the
case yeah
honestly it does let's use when I'm
watching this it seems fine all the time
and then I will see comments about you
know I'm not getting it recommended I
haven't I have a couple accounts on my
phone and I check and make sure I'm
still getting the notifications and
sometimes I don't get notifications some
of those accounts and sometimes I do get
notifications of shows live on some
accounts so but I mean the Turning Point
USA thing was really weird yeah because
I get off the stage and then I'm told
immediately the show didn't go live for
like 10 minutes it didn't go live very
stressful for the rest of us backstage
being like what is happening because we
could see it in the monitors but we you
know like the first thing I did was pull
up on YouTube and and you think maybe
there'll be a 30 second delay right like
you think it's a big show I don't
remember how long our lag is anyways
whatever like it doesn't kick in and we
all sort of turn to each other like when
was it this was uh how long ago was in
December yeah a couple months oh yeah
right end of November
15 yeah
fairly recent as a quick aside the poll
says uh people think the FBI ran and 55
say it was a cover-up 45 say deep State
removal but uh again we had we we had on
more than one occasion Luke would start
talking about the intelligence agencies
and things they've done and then all of
a sudden the show would drop for like 20
seconds or something we could double
blind test on Rumble I mean that's
that's some advice is we could try a
different platform and see if it happens
again and the other thing is it happens
spottily and it could be not even
alphabet the company it could be like
well
now and continue talking about the CIA
and the FBI and see if it drops off yeah
I don't know it is definitely certain
topics it's definitely topic based I'm
loathe to go that direction to start
assuming for sure that it's because of
the topic yeah I can understand why you
would be I get it and you have you
honestly have more uh you know
experience with this than I would but to
in my experience it seems like it's
topic based and what I've seen and in
the past I've watched a show for years
it definitely seems like there's you
know can you guys listening uh admitting
at YouTube right now Super Chat us and
let us know if there are Tech
Technologies I'm using to mute and oh
there's things they have to have it just
let us know you know how I I guarantee
you I I I would say there is no less
than a 100 chance they have that ability
you know why because a crackpot
psychopath live streamed himself going
into a church in New Zealand right right
that kind of stuff has happened before
it's happened more than once and I'm
sure when that happened to every big
Tech platform said we need the ability
to instantly shut down any stream game
we need robot AI whatever tracking
noises YouTube has a rule that you
cannot do anything with guns live
so if you don't so if you if you're on
YouTube and you have a gun Channel you
can go out to your range and do
tutorials and like um
um who's that uh who's what's that gun
Channel Hickok45 I think is a good one
yeah have you ever seen it yeah and so
everything that's all fine and they're
like yeah you can do that's totally fine
because it's recording not live though
right yeah and it has to be in the
proper setting so it can only be at a
gun shop to display the weapon or it can
be on the Range where it's safe
so I'm willing to bet they've got
workers and Ai and I bet the workers get
alerted when the AI Flags something
right yeah and there's also a lot of
pressure from all of these different
organizations with a lot of money
um on social media platforms to censor
content to you know go after
discrimination hate speech uh violence
Etc so you know what about remember all
those uh Facebook uh sensors who are not
necessarily sensors but they were I
think they would be considered sensors
they were watching Facebook material and
so there's uploaded to Facebook to check
it with her wasn't that a whole big
story and that kind of disappeared they
were talking about how it was you know
detrimental to their health how they
could like they were watching so much
negative content all the time and it was
like damaging them remember that well
Ian did it too yeah I did a video about
that in 2018 that was start right after
that idea broke 2017 when people started
coming out they'll hire people to look
at the darkest drags if you mean I mean
stuff will go up on YouTube are you
talking about the tick tock lawsuit I'm
so sorry oh no problem no no I'm talking
about like because there was a tick tock
on Facebook yeah the sensors are seeing
so much yeah murder and child abuse yeah
you know there's there was a tick tock
contract sure Tick Tock contracts to a
third party and they filed a class
action lawsuit for some more reason I'm
sure your videos the third party filed
one against Tick Tock yeah for damages
because they say they just see terrible
awful things and they have to like
they'll work part of it is like they'll
work really long shifts right and then
like without a break from anything
they're just taking in all this terrible
yeah it's not it was 24 7 for me so I'd
go in I'd look at 300 things I'd go out
an hour later I'd go back in look at
another 100 things stuff like that this
is all day of my life for five years so
that was my life for those that are
wondering why Ian is the way he is he
has to be normal and he's looked at
these things and he became more and more
Twisted I did used to be normal
um I used to watch bangedup.com you ever
watch those old like Faces of Death
shows and stuff like in 2001 when the
internet was finally on and I could
finally watch a video I'd go on America
Online
um yeah it was I think I had America
online at the time and um and that was
like hard to watch I was like happens I
should I should be able to see it if
it's going to happen in real life I
should see it but like that doesn't mean
I need to see every blown open body yeah
it's important for me to protect the
mind and uh I don't know how we're gonna
handle administrating these things right
this is the this is a big challenge
because there are evil people posting
evil stuff on all these platforms and
you know Elon of course came in and that
was a big thing he was trying to do is
get rid of this stuff because Twitter
certainly wasn't for whatever reason let
me pull up this story this is this is a
crazy story this is from our good
friends over at Jezebel you know Jezebel
you know
twitch twitch's AI porn controversy is a
creepy sign of things to come you know I
completely agree with Jezebel for once
popular streamer attracts sobbed through
his apology after viewers spotted that
he was looking at AI generated porn of
other streamers this is the weirdest
thing ever so the dude I guess like
what's the story he was what he had porn
pulled up on his no he like so pop
culture crisis shout out to them talked
about this the other day he like was
doing a stream and he was clicking
through like the tabs and I guess I
don't know if he opened accidentally or
just skipped over it but like they could
see he was on PornHub and I don't know
all the details of like how they
identified that it was what it is it
wasn't PornHub for my image it was a
site that does this you can like upload
someone's face in his apology he said I
was on PornHub and I got directed to an
app right exactly and then it sent me to
whoever something that's what I figured
out but like they noticed a tab in his
browser that was like it was crying
about it yeah
his wife is crying too he was on point
he was like I was on porn of a totally
normal site and then I an ad popped up
famously an ad popped up for this AI
deep fake porn so he clicked on it and
then he went the extra step to pay money
to get an account for the connecting to
watch can I just give some advice to any
uh you know young streamers out there
you have a work computer and you have a
personal computer it's not hard to
understand but this guy apparently was
like I run my business off this machine
let's pull up adult content on the
browser I use yeah for children come on
bro like a streamer for like a year a
long time right like I think he was I
don't know anything about him but
obviously he was live what am I saying
think yeah but I just mean like you you
think he'd know to close his tabs yeah
seriously bro come on just don't do that
on your work computer just don't do it
at all in my opinion true true as the
story was breaking what's this girl's
name out of a morbid curiosity he paid
for a subscription
so curious please have my money and show
me more yeah I think he's in damage
control at this point but hold on like
how I mean it is it is kind of CR it is
creepy right it's creepy so then what
what do you do right if there's like
some sort of initiative to censor this
sort of content that's worse I mean I
don't know yeah someone someone tweeted
this and I saw it's got to 11 600 quote
tweets this tweet has 36 million views
this guy I uh ion romaro says
millionaire internet streamers reaction
to AI porn of herself you won't find
more fragile people than popular
internet personalities especially women
I don't know if I agree um I think
you're allowed to be freaked out that
someone took a picture of your face and
put it on porn and is like watching it
she says people keep sending screenshots
of it to her like all these people have
seen it and it's got her face on it and
then like I mean it happens to
celebrities all the time doesn't it you
know their faces are drama did this yeah
remember when when fry was dating Lucy
lubot oh yeah yeah he had Lucy Liu
downloaded into a robot so you could
date her yeah well that's true I already
used example pop culture but uh Japan
has this big issue with importing sex
dolls and they've agreed to release some
but they won't release any that look
like a public figure or like a child
what the yeah because they're like
that's disgusting so what's a public
figure at the end of days well I know
like how do you define what a public
figure exactly do you have to be in a
magazine to be in a movie also how are
like all of the people so you can do it
to regular people or like 2 000
followers on it's like what point yeah
exactly it's terrifying and like there
have been a lot of people saying they
shouldn't be upset about this but like I
think people will compare it to like oh
it's like a sex tape getting weak but
like this girl who's crying about it
like didn't didn't do that like I
mean
she's also not making money off of it
and I'm sure that's not her point but
yeah that's part of her Point yeah yeah
but she should get all the money from it
she should it's her lightness like you
can't take a picture of Ian and put it
on like a commercial for your soda pop
you got to pay in for that well you can
do it but you will pay me for it if you
do no no look at this look at this this
tweet from sweet Anita said the story
was how I found out that I'm on this
website I literally choose to pass up
Millions by not going into sex work and
some random Cheeto encrusted porn
addicts unless it's my body without my
consent instead don't know whether
whether the cry breaks up or laugh at
this point I just don't think this
should be the price for wanting to
entertain people this made me realize
something
there's a lot of women who try to do
only fans they could effectively have
like like porn star surrogates you know
yeah like you don't have to extrude
themselves but here's here's but here's
the problem that's that's the thing I'm
saying like there could be women who are
like get a different woman to do the
work for you just put your face on it
but here's the crazy thing
you can't do anything about it so we're
we're talking about we're working on
music and we were talking with some some
you know industry guys and they were
like you guys should do a cover of a
song you know people like covers and
then you do like maybe just like one
cover of something as like a song you
really like you want to do and I'm like
well how do you do that I mean we got to
buy the right no you just do it no
because I'm like fine you don't need to
buy the rights to cover a song like no
the money just goes to the person who
wrote the song right I was like oh wow
now think about what that means for AI
deep porn that means any woman anywhere
can't stop someone from making it the
only thing they can do is accept the
money this basically means like you
cannot stop someone from forcing a woman
to be in in in AI porn yeah the only
thing that happens is like well they
used your face so here's money so how do
you deal with this that's the question I
don't know the girl in the video and I I
apologize I don't know her name GT
Cinderella I mean like I feel bad for
her she's not happening to her but how
do you how do you deal she says one of
her frustrations now she's taking she's
spending her own money to fight it and
like in court and stuff and I guess like
you issue a cease and desist like but
the other part is good luck also it's
already out there like even if you get
this one video of her taken down it
doesn't end the surface and also like
is going to be able to write it on the
spot you'll go I want to watch Person a
have sex with animal L and then they
watch a donkey and uh the woman you love
getting it on and then you like okay
stop I want to watch myself having sex
with fill in the blank and it's that's
it and everyone in the world is fair
game you could even be I want to look at
a blend of person A and B having sex
with person Y and you'll see like these
weird dude people are gonna like put the
Hulk's face on a woman I remember we
were talking about that weird YouTube
thing where they put Hitler's head on a
woman's body to do tai chi and sing
nursery rhymes to kids
man the world is is getting technology
it feels like thank you it feels like
chaos is taking over it's just
everything's becoming random nonsense
and chaotic but then eventually it'll
become normalized and then people you
know that's why I asked if we'll be
around in 14 years that this country's
can still it's like we used to be able
to defend Earth because of land borders
they had artillery they rolled up to the
Border we could protect it with troops
they couldn't get any closer in so they
couldn't hit the target now we have air
power you can't protect the earth when
everyone has air power there's no way to
defend the American process of Defending
Earth is not functional now because you
have orbital strikes and stuff climate
change is supposed to kill us by 2025 so
so wait these websites allow you to like
you upload someone else's picture and
then it'll generate it for you yeah I
know they do those we we did the thing
with the music video genocide if you
haven't seen heard the song genocide
check it out because Ian's in it and we
we animated news personality faces to
sing the song about it's basically
criticizing the media for being Liars
yeah so I know that that sounds like you
know kind of wholesome it's silly to
like make Don Lemon sing or whatever but
people are actually going totally dark
with it it's crazy I I wanted to get an
account and check it out earlier today
but I stopped myself
not enough morbid curiosity you know
what I would actually rather do I would
rather just use it use like the AI
technology to put Tom Cruise in just
whatever movie so like I want to see Tom
Cruise as Frodo Baggins and then do a
voice Ai and a face Ai and then it's
literally just Tom Cruise as Frodo bangs
the whole time tell me that would not be
like the funnest thing ever it would be
fun to have technology if everyone had
good intentions right but like you can't
introduce that you have to assume
everyone's gonna do the worst thing
which is like you know AI generated porn
like I'm sorry but that's the reality I
mean people can already do that with
like Adobe programs and everything but
you know your face on video and Etc so
it's true I don't like anything to AI
they're just making it easier with AI to
do that yeah of course but I think
that's like that's why you so many
parents are deciding not to put their
kids faces on the internet right that's
why you saw this pushback against like
family family Vlog channels I think that
like
we had a nice honeymoon here here with
technology and the internet we thought
it was cool we thought it was a fun time
but actually it's extremely dangerous it
is and there's no putting it back in the
box so should you just
I'm just worried about what politicians
are gonna propose to stop this from
happening oh I got an idea we should uh
AI Biden's face on a Trump's body and
then start showing it to people and be
like do you agree with what Joe Biden
says here yep totally and it'll be Joe
Biden but come on man you know I'm the
greatest president everybody agrees yeah
that's a good idea we could honestly do
like a Nancy Pelosi or a foucho and you
haven't did voices down
I feel like uh
it's it's inevitable that everyone's
going to be defect onto porn of all
styles yeah so I've just kind of already
accepted it like get ready for the
Whirlwind but the problem is when people
don't know it's a deep fake when they
see it yeah and then they post that's
the problem
when it happens so often and people are
gonna just be like oh it's probably fake
video ever no I'm not going to believe
anything what is real
taking child porn and you go to the cops
and they're like nah everything's fake
it's the matter but it's a real case
like what do we do they would have the
means to you know sort of investigate it
but you just said to it that everyone's
gonna assume it's all fake everyone is
in general public but I guess forensics
will dig through it yeah if they are
motivated enough to right if we assume
enough of it is fake I'm just saying
like it opens this terrible door where
people are gonna be like the reality is
most this stuff is not real but like
what's real that's the question is is it
the perception of the act or is it the
act itself because when you watch porn a
video you're not actually watching the
porn you're watching a digital
representation of us you're not watching
porn for real you're watching a a
fantasy um
that's a semantic argument but we think
it's real because we feel it because it
happened because people filmed it we're
asking the question of whether or not it
was filmed with real humans or was made
by a computer and it never happened if
it looks identical like what's if
there's no difference there is was a
person in this act or not and if we're
talking about children was it children
harmed and raped or as an adult who
consented and got paid I mean those are
questions you can't
a video evidence of a crime or not
that's that's you know very simple but
until those if I don't think those
questions can be answered if it looks
realistic and if there's no way to know
well I should be able to answer it like
you said I'm not saying hey Authority is
going to fix it I don't know I'm not
entirely convinced because this is
something we've been talking about for
several years okay and it's going to
come to a point where what you do is you
create an you you generate a fake video
then you come you run through a
compressor or or uh you convert it and
now it it wipes out the artifacts yeah
it's gonna be it's going to be hard to
tell at a certain really good job
interesting yeah yep it's creepy I was
watching um
I was watching some YouTube videos like
some blizzard thing or something I
remember what it was no no no no uh yeah
yeah I can't remember what it was and it
was like
it was kind of really obvious it was CGI
but just the lighting was so good I was
like weird it was like they got past The
Uncanny Valley that's what it felt like
it felt like you knew it was CGI but it
looked so good and real and it was like
a person walking like across a bridge or
something and I was like damn this is
creepy that's crazy stuff man yeah I to
go back to the crying girl for just a
second because on my mind
um the other thing I think she could do
legally is go after PornHub because if
they're accepting advertising money from
this site I don't really I'm not a
lawyer I don't know I think she could no
okay but like you gotta go to the
company that did it not the advertising
like you can't she can maybe do a cease
and desist if they're showing her
picture on the side or something I feel
like there is like that's what's
weirding me out like and then I'm not
gonna start a new wave of lawsuits I
know but like that's the thing about
legal fights like everyone involved has
to have the money to go through it and
even then they're not always effective
like there's really no justice for this
and they're also buying his story about
that's what happened oh yeah for sure
sure totally but like we did I feel like
and I don't know I'm not gonna
investigate it but like him being like
these are advertising they see there are
enough people who check out PornHub who
could verify oh yeah they run those
advertisements which is like to me
creepy I'm like I got a weird gross man
yeah it's terrible I met like a
Crossroads in my mind because I'm like a
pretty extreme techno libertarian like I
think if the technology can exist it's
gonna exist and it will get used no
amount of legalities are going to stop
that technology from being real uh
but then I'm like well wait a minute I'm
thinking about protecting children and
like how do you
how to you know you can't just let
everyone see everything all the time
where where we're going like remember
lenza that it was a big thing it's I
guess people are still doing it the AI
pictures like the cartoon pictures and
everything you take a bunch of pictures
of yourself and it generates like a
perfect AI version of you or whatever
that's the future we're gonna live in
the pods and you're gonna be in a
digital world and you know the funny
thing is like for all we know we're
already in it and we are the beautiful
versions of ourselves dude I just pulled
up this story from last year on Yahoo
would you eat lab-grown human salami
cultured from celebrity cells oh they're
making meat from celebrities so they're
about to and then you can eat your
favorite celebrity or what is the title
of that one would you eat lab-grown
human salami why would you want to do
that yes why what is the motivation
because you want to live in the Pod and
be your best fantasy what do you think
it brings you closer to them if you like
all right let's look at this point human
meat grown in a lab would you eat human
meat because well this is like um the
animal rights movement really because
they don't want you to eat
animal meat the answer is no I won't eat
human what is wrong with you people did
you find the one about Labyrinth salami
cultured from celebrities lab groans
I've seen that human being oh here we go
before it's it's like an animal right
would you eat lab-grown human salami
cultured from celebrity cells no why so
large
salami they're hoping to get James
Franco and Ellen DeGeneres Jennifer
Lawrence and Kanye West on board donate
tissue samples that will become Solano I
don't think Kanye will be down knowing I
don't think he'd be down with that you
make a lot could you imagine the amount
of money that someone could make
probably so much it's only legal in
Idaho though Idaho's unless it allows
that this is like some of the most
disgusting stuff I've ever seen yo we
need to go back there was also another
joke not too far too far too far there's
also an article I read um they said
would you eat
um human meat to save the planet
here's what I'm saying how about I think
I have this video somewhere here we go
check out this video
this is uh I saw this history defined
High School fitness program in 1962.
Sierra High School has developed a
program that assures every student of
physical look at this
this is normal back then for all of the
kids somebody filmed last year right now
you can't even play dodgeball
so extension first of all boys school or
they separate by gender I'm pretty sure
they all did so I'm kind of saying
here's what I'm saying can we like go
back to when we you know exercise and
ate right but you know keep the getting
rid of racism part and then just have
like the not racism but still be
exercising and eating right and not
having human grown well this is toxic
masculinity now this is just a bunch of
teenagers exercising as they should be
but nowadays it's just like the kids sit
around doing nothing well if you make
them exercise and they can't do it then
you make them feel bad and that's bad
because that's bullying man it's like
it's like social Darwinism or whatever
strong must survive let the let the
people who want to be doughy be doing
those people want to be fit be fit do
you want to cater to like the lowest
denominator or should we all like try to
encourage everyone to reach their
Highest Potential right that's why we're
gonna lower the standards oh good that's
part of like the assisted suicide
conversation like I'm very much just
cater to the best of the best and let
everyone else fall away if they can't
keep up then they're not supposed to
evolutionarily see with this June class
example I feel like it's way worse to be
like you couldn't do a push-up so you
just don't have to do them like we know
you're not capable that's a terrible
thing to communicate to a teenager right
being like hey you can't do push-up but
by the end of the semester maybe you'll
be able to do five and that's awesome
that's an improvement like that's way
better shaving or something exactly
yeah I guess there's if we are going
into the Techno verse that your emotions
are going to be a key part in your
ability to navigate so angry people
could make bad things and you want to
like make sure people are happy and
healthy but the problem is man giving
someone everything they want when
they're little is not what makes people
happy you need people need averse
adversity they need competition of
course they need to lose and they need
to learn how to enjoy it
that's how you do the future is going to
be humans are going to be short and
gangly and gaunt super thin wearing
jumpsuits and they're going to live in
pods but in the pods they're going to be
six feet tall super ripped flying around
you know with with spaceships and all
that stuff yeah
ever so I think the future is androgyny
because we see all of this gender
transitioning happening and I think that
the idea will eventually be you know an
androgynous model yeah I was thinking
that we're going to be just raising
gestating and like pods the kids and
then adults won't have sex organs will
be super tall because we'll be in Low
Gravity have really long arms and legs
have you guys watched sg1
this is basically what happens to one of
the aliens like the the alien there what
are they the the nordics what do they
call them I forgot what they call them
in the show uh but they're like Grays
and they can't reproduce anymore they
can only clone themselves and they're
they're they're degrading so they can't
do it much longer and they eventually
just get wiped out because of it what
were you about to oh I was like to say
in the early 2000s I remember reading
some fashion magazine to a cover on like
the Top Model yeah sorry guys the
highest like most in demand and it was a
man who was known for his androgynous
look and he's very thin and like Tim
saying like long arms stuff like that
yeah the fashion industry to this day is
doing the same well and this was like I
think I read this article in 2010 right
so at that time they already were like
this is the ideal for both men and women
because they were saying this like he's
able to walk runway for men's lines but
also for women's lines right but he's
not shaped like we would think a
traditional toxically masculine male
ideally is and he's not
and how do we get to that ideal of
androgyny by flipping so and making
the body unhealthy right right so the
fashion industry they're making men wear
dresses and then they're making women
you know wear more masculine clothing so
that is the first step to reaching that
ideal of androgyny so I think that
definitely and they're 10 years ahead
like if we're just talking about it now
they've already known it for a while I
was thinking like how uh all wars are
fought for sex I don't know some people
have told me that over time like all all
wars are fought over women or some some
like that so that's the Helena Troy
that's like the one thing I'm pretty
sure a lot of us wars in the world were
fought over uh black peppercorn oh
wasn't it salt well I guess so all
seasons all that stuff food for sure but
the aggression over over women over
either guys not getting laid so he goes
he gets angry or a guy wants the woman
so he goes like maybe the sexuality is
what has caused us to be so psychotic as
a species is our obsession with finding
a mate and taking other people's mates
and I disagree as an explained the East
India Trading Company uh trade company
and the the spot
it was literally
pepper black pepper they were like I
will kill thousands to make my eggs
taste better it was it's also the profit
off the black pepper the amount of money
they could make what about female
leaders that go to war like Boudicca I
mean Margaret Thatcher for example not
true yeah not all war is for sex
obviously that's ridiculous but it's for
pepper a lot of male aggression yes
because of it I think in nature male
aggression is often because of female
stuff like you think about like the I
remember what they are but the Rams that
got interlocked because they're trying
to beat each other to like how do you
define male aggression just displays of
aggression right so if you're talking
about these Rams they fight each other
being a man I mean I think aggression is
a naturally masculine intention that's
what I'm saying but like the
uh there are times when it becomes fatal
right if your land Rams who lock
together and die because you're trying
to seduce it or show the girl that like
you were the better stronger the two
like it can be at times not the best you
need a certain amount of aggression you
don't need to doubt it but like I think
you're right we link a in nature sex and
aggression are often linked but I don't
think it's necessarily the only cause of
War I wonder if it's being bred out of
humanity if people are attempting to
lower the aggression and the sexuality
to an androgynous State it's crossed my
mind like five ten years ago and I
wonder if it's a technocratic state of
mind thing like we need these people not
testosterone filled because they're too
much too much fist fights too much lying
so that's physical aggression but then
on the female side there's emotional
aggression right because I mean they're
influenced by estrogen and everything so
yeah and aggression yeah I feel like
it's worse I would do but I think it's
well they have that thing where they say
like men like women like men if there's
a problem like eventually can just hit
each other right yeah but with women
like and then you'll get over it yeah
yeah but they're hitting each other
never never solves it I don't think and
I don't think so but they assert
dominance and that's sort of the natural
order of like the difference between men
and women it does solve it though right
the beef is over it solves it in the
physical sense like the guy's not gonna
do you think that the dudes are like
emotionally upset with each other after
they win a fight or something probably I
mean if you're not working it out
emotionally or or consciously like I
don't think it's getting worked out
what's the kind of fighter do you mean
like a guy and two guys want a woman
they get into a fist fight the guy
breaks the other guy's legs breaks his
neck and now he's like he didn't just he
didn't okay
we're at tribal now so we have no choice
because otherwise we'll come back later
um yeah and it's kind of crazy if you
think about it I was in Norway and the
Norwegian is Norwegian guy and it's
funny because they're all kind of woke
he was like you want to hear a joke and
I was like and he's like how come
Britain has no beautiful women and I was
like why
and then uh I was like oh it was right
because the Vikings went and raided and
took all the women and I'm like I don't
know if that's a joke or like it's not
but the crazy thing is like I'm imagine
like you're a woman in a village in like
the British house or whatever in Great
Britain or something or Wales or
Scotland and then all of a sudden a
bunch of Burly dudes on a boat just walk
up destroy your village and take you and
bring you back to their Village and it's
like this is your life now yeah true
like that's just it like okay I guess
yeah God I you know the horrible I talk
about this horrible horrible stuff but
it's only because I want people to think
about what it could be you can't just
call call the cops like if we really
screw this up you know this American
thing
watch watch 18 I'm watching 1883 because
you know you guys were telling me to
watch it yeah yeah it's just like
everybody dying all the time it's a bit
ridiculous it's just like they're
walking and then all of a sudden like
one there's like there's a scene where
they're talking about this and a girl
goes to take a leak or something and a
snake bites her ass and then she's dead
like her corpse is laying on the ground
like what else make better ass look I
think that what was that video game was
popular organ Trail like I don't think
it prepared us for what the West was
really like that's why I liked watching
YouTube
the way they did like this where the
Marshall walks into the room and he's
like who did it bang bang bang just
kills everybody I'd say the depictions
of law enforcement and how that works
but like the risk to The Travelers like
while they're going like the snakes in
the wagon and the whatever else like
that is real right it seems kind of
crazy today because
there are there are very like
rudimentary things we've learned like in
grade school that can really make a
difference that they didn't know and if
you think about it like just it's to put
it simply there were people at a time
who didn't know what a wheel was
and we all know what a wheel is because
we've just seen it we've never had a
workshop class on how to make a wheel we
probably struggle to figure out how to
make a perfect wheel out of wood or
something but eventually we'd figure out
something how to make something roll but
there was a period where people didn't
have wheels nobody figured it out nobody
knew nobody saw it now it's like if we
really needed to you could probably make
a wheel with something you just do it
because you know the concept of it so
when it comes to like the Oregon Trail
there's a bunch of stuff you may have
just seen passively watching the
Discovery Channel and you're like oh
yeah you know like how to get water at
night it's like you dig a little hole
and you put like a leaf in it or
something and you get like a cup or
whatever condensation forms and it drips
into the cup there's just like stuff
that you learn from watching movies that
these people never had access to think
about this well germ Theory right sorry
oh right yeah like washing wounds they
used to be like why wash your hands yeah
or like you have to boil your water
before you drink it right they didn't
know that because they didn't have the
concepts but energy three they're
boiling the water because of Cholera but
they have to tell them to right but so
so think about this
when you watch a movie you get a bunch
of BS information and people think the
wrong things from watching it though
that people think that like silencers
make guns go you you they really don't
and uh they really don't know what these
things sound like but um there's there
is a there is so much information we
absorb every single day that we take for
granted if you go back to 1883 you
probably absorbed no information for for
days like literally the information you
absorb is like an animal was there okay
well that's not like longevity
information right I'm talking like today
you know I'll read an article and it'll
be like a new Fusion reactor it it
combines these things with these things
I'm like I don't know I just learned
some I guess and I don't know I want to
practically apply like a fusion reactor
or something but you go back to the
1800s and you're walking the whole day
and you learn nothing new the only thing
new you learn is like there's a tree at
this point on the map you know we've
also seen this transition from you know
TV culture to internet culture right we
have all of the world's knowledge at our
fingertips 24 7. you know
30 years ago we wouldn't be able to
Google like some stupid you know piece
of information that we were looking for
but now we can it's crazy that was
actually uh that was a comic I think it
was XKCD I'm not sure where someone it's
like 1990 and someone said hey what year
was Lincoln shot another person's like I
don't know you want to go to the library
and find out nah and then it's like now
hey what year was Lincoln shot then he's
looking at his phone he's like 1864. I
don't know was it 1864 what year was it
that he was shot 1865 was like 24 ended
right yeah right after the war right it
was like a month after the war ended
yeah 65 65. that makes sense right can't
go anywhere without your history what
year was it April 14th 1865. 55. you
were right right I was close I was close
yeah to this point you know um when I
had that Twitter space with the Taliban
I was telling you about before I
co-hosted it with Nuance bro and we were
discussing the detainment of Andrew Tate
and I got Mega people together with
these Taliban guys living in Afghanistan
they actually had a very fruitful
conversation about you know where the
world was headed can you imagine if we
could do this back in 2000
yeah that's why I'm wondering why do we
have this global conflict like where is
Putin on a video chat with Joe Biden
Q YouTube taking us up here we're gonna
go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member over at timcast.com to watch our
uncensored members only show which will
be up around 11 p.m tonight so we do
those Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
and as a member you're supporting our
cultural Endeavors and our show so we
really do appreciate it smash that like
button all that good stuff all right I
prefer Rumble do you says Tim and Ian
please check out 2034 a novel of the
next World War by Admiral James Steph
stav Rivas it's sobering and clearly
shows it explains World War III will
touch American soil technology is a
double-edged blade
yeah drone bombers man defiant blackout
says yo Tim when you started off with
that raid comment YouTube glitched and I
replayed it that whole part is gone
about the orange man
let me just make sure I can reiterate
this and I'm going to give advanced
warning for our sensors so you can okay
I'm about to say it again all right
When Donald Trump has the FBI go to his
house to look for documents it's a raid
when they go to Joe Biden's house house
office it's a planned search it's funny
how the media does that right all right
did you guys did the sensors did you get
it oh no that one went through uh well
you tried you tried all right Bryce he
says Tim your stream cut out for a few
seconds in the beginning when you were
talking about the Biden raid did it now
Richard winter says I'm pretty sure
YouTube just censored you saying Donald
Trump in your opening did they now look
at all these people saying this huh
just a coincidence don't question it
Rasta says just some feedback on an
earlier vid from today the 4u algorithm
existed before Elon bought the site but
Elon just made it easier to switch from
for you and actually following on the
app uh anyway love you all yes there was
a little there were little stars in the
top right and you had the home feed and
the latest feed and every so often it
would automatically switch you back to
home which was algorithmic
yeah I think it's awful
all right Darius
Darius Arkin says shortly after having a
discussion with my district manager
where I was told that my conservative
politics are unacceptable my transfer
request was denied and I was terminated
from my position yes well if that was
Washington DC you'd have a case for a
human rights violation where politics is
a protected class is that crazy it
doesn't play anywhere else though for
the most part
all right let's see Matthew reckham says
the problem with your poll is it doesn't
have a third option for both that was
the poll on the question of is are they
trying to remove Biden or cover up the
the raid or cover up Biden smell Seasons
yep David Toronto says Trump was
President he can declassify documents
Joe couldn't either way I'll take
president DeSantis well there you go
that's one simple answer I guess
what do you guys think is it me DeSantis
I hope for Trump do you like Trump I
prefer Trump and stuff man I think
DeSantis is pretty much like the same
GOP establishment type of guy that's
using wokism to basically capture the
Maga base right I think so like he's
doing what they want to try and earn
their favor yeah I mean that's kind of
what he should be doing yeah but I I
just don't think this is
Trump yeah I I understand that and
that's one criticism I have of trump but
then he ended up firing Bolton you know
he brought in he brought in a bunch of
people he had a bunch of people
surrounding him as Luke likes to point
out he tried to get Bill Gates to be an
advisor right so it's it's tough like
Trump was not perfect I don't know man
yeah he wasn't and that's actually why I
I trust him more he's not a politician
he's not a traditional politician
whereas DeSantis you know he's born and
bred politician really too polish maybe
yeah all right Christina H says Caitlyn
Bennett said she'd love to come on the
show I hope you guys get in contact soon
uh I will I will figure that one out let
me write that down let me write down uh
Caitlin Bennett that'd be cool I haven't
seen her in a while
has she been on before I think they were
saying she took a break because she's a
mom
um
that's where Jalen went Kent State
college she used to interview people and
she'd have like the gun and then yeah
she's still really curly hair too right
no yeah and three four five says they
are going to have Hakeem Jeffrey's run
really though it's kind of soon but but
that would boost his profile like Nikki
Haley is gonna run and she doesn't
actually expect to win running for
president makes you it boosts your
profile you sell books
yeah and that's that's the only reason
they do it they do it so that they get a
book contract and make a bunch of money
right say they ran
all right really Rick says Hey Samira
it's gays for Trump when can we expect
the next Taliban Twitter space
very soon hopefully pick a topic and
then you know maybe you can join you
guys should join that's super
interesting yeah so how many people from
the Taliban come on normally
um I mean that was a very specific
Twitter space but then you know they'll
show up in our spaces sometimes you know
Nuance bro said they like asked yeah
they were asking for dating advice or
something yeah we don't know what you're
talking about
no they have good advice and you know
we've asked them about pop culture
references and everything so yeah I mean
I'm hoping to you know get these groups
together you know would be good
conversation all right Wyatt caldenberg
says Tim I have been involved in
politics since the 60s one thing I
learned never trust people who spread
gossip and create drama within the
movement they always turn out to be paid
rats crackpot or people with dark
secrets well the one thing I will say is
we talked about reputation management
firms a while back these are companies
that their whole thing is how to create
personas how to manufacture identities
and how to do the inverse how to destroy
and character assassinate and so the one
thing I'll warn you about is like with
Julian Assange this is the this is where
the future of of assassination is back
in the day let's just let's just leave
all the conspiracy theories aside
several prominent people were killed in
you know big news stories what happens
when a prominent individual has their
life taken while their work stops but
their ideas become immortal they become
Martyrs yeah what we see now is Julian
Assange gets accused of some impropriety
or nonsense that turns out to be totally
fake they use that as pretext to shut
down his work or at least impede to the
best of their abilities and try and
Destroy his legacy so that his ideas die
forever the man gets to live locked in
the Ecuadorian Embassy for 10 years but
they made sure that all across the
internet people were spamming comments
about how Julian Assange was doing with
this that or otherwise to women the
median narratives came out started doing
all the same thing and it was all a lie
and then what it turned out turns out
they dropped the case against Julian
Assange and then Donald Trump moved to
have him uh indicted and extradited to
the United States on Espionage charges
when he's not even an American citizen
right you got to watch out for this
Intel stuff man yeah they try it's weird
stuff it's weird creepy stuff but you
can usually tell when it's inorganic
like
like the the story about Julian Assange
if you actually looked into you knew
like oh okay this is not real but for
some reason the New York Times or
whoever else all these big news outlets
were writing overtly fake things the
same thing I can say for Donald Trump
like all these people spamming on
Twitter screaming about how Trump said
Nazis were very fine people and it's
like yo he never did that yeah so who
are these people doing this well you
know I think it is I think it's a mix of
prominent high profile accounts that get
the intelligence agencies of the
contractors will reach out to them and
say hey this is the go here's your rate
like here's your pay do this story or
they will spam prominent personalities
on the left and say like hey look like
all of a sudden 50 comments will appear
on someone's page being like Donald
Trump said this Donald Trump said this
troll farms and then these prominent
personalities will start talking about
it and regurgitating these ideas and
then saying Donald Trump's a Nazi
because and then it creates that moment
the reputation management firm is really
look into it that's what Wikipedia is
run by basically can a handful of
different agencies and individuals who
do what's called reputation management
and then what's really dirty is when
campaigns Target an individual for some
reason that you can't really understand
and then the person goes to them and
says hey we can fix this for you maybe
you just pay us and we'll make it all go
away we'll handle your Wikipedia page
and get those articles removed crazy
stuff right yeah all right let's see we
got
cabaro says the DS can run a decrepit
senile alleged pedo and make him get 81
million ballots it doesn't matter who
the establishment decides to run that's
what I'm saying like these it look
people are going to get a universal
mail-in ballot and then someone's gonna
knock on their door and say vote for
bidening on whatever I guess and they're
not gonna know anything about them
Joe Biden could walk into Fifth Avenue
and and at the point of that statement
is it's what Trump said Trump said he'd
go on Fifth Avenue and he wouldn't lose
a single vote he was right I mean it's
not a good thing you know obviously but
he's not he's not wrong in the zealotry
of a lot of these voters it's not
exclusive to Trump I think that's the
important thing yeah
all right what do we got grafty says the
UFO might spin at some point buck well
you know here you go the UFO might spin
there it is a little
air duster to spin
spinning the UFO is that's it all right
that's danger wobbling the UFO might
yeah you have to make sure it's
perfectly flat otherwise the air is
pushing it down I think hypothetically
if something spins horizontally fast
enough it creates anti-gravity it
diminishes its vertical momentum to zero
that doesn't make sense I'll talk I'll
bring on Jeremy risk the alien scientist
to explain it at some point in the
future so the challenge with this UFO is
that it's not symmetrical in every
direction so when the the blower is on
it it's pushing it slightly downward and
so it's going down but then bouncing up
so it starts wobbling so what you have
to do is you have to get it perfectly
flat and aligned I've got this thing to
go really really fast where the whole
thing starts shaking like crazy because
it can't handle the energy but I kind of
feel like there's got to be a way to
make it spin perfectly
you know like what's the maximum RPM for
this UFO
oh my gosh because there's a vacuum
there I I don't know if there would be a
maximum I mean it actually would break
apart right it would throw itself apart
I watched this really funny video um a
skateboard wheel and they put uh they
put like a power tool on it so that it
would Spin and it's it spins so fast
this is urethane it's hard it's like
it's it melts basically it just like
wobbles out like Laffy Taffy did you
ever watch the hydraulic press YouTube
channel where he just smashes different
things I love that channel therapeutic
all right what do we got here Brian uh
Bryant laws says question what if this
is the setup for civil war too think
about it Lincoln wasn't a perfect choice
for POTUS so would Newsom be in the same
boat I don't know is is Joe Biden our
Buchanan maybe Lincoln came out as a
fourth part there are four parties
running for president that year and he
was kind of a nobody uh wasn't a
politician and it was just a radical
time in history so it is possible that
we're about to embark on like we were
just talking earlier we need uh at least
I was saying I think more political
parties the difference is now we have
bought Farms troll Farms run by these
parties and intelligence agencies I
think that they've been doing it for a
while yeah I actually talked to uh uh
I'll just say a political party guy and
this was probably seven or eight years
ago who was talking about basically this
you know they're they're not so overt
they don't come out and say we want to
make trolls to Target individuals or
anything like that they're just like we
want to maximize
yeah and what was the share blue was it
the company that hired people to go on
Reddit and post comments or something
if you ever wonder why it is that you're
online you're seeing it's just a massive
you're getting inundated with a bunch of
comments that like come out of nowhere
you got to watch out for these companies
like share blue or whatever is that what
it's called this is from Daily Beast
Hillary the Hillary Clinton pack spent a
million dollars to quote correct
commenters in Facebook exactly share it
blue yep that's right
the the internet is fake debt internet
Theory companies uh Reddit is the most
one of the so Reddit was was the uh
what made videos go viral yeah people
would find a video find it funny put it
on Reddit and then it would go viral
because the engine works that way if you
liked it you give it an up vote if you
did it went down so if the video had
that X Factor more people are uploading
it than downvoting it it starts
skyrocketing then people figured out how
to game the algorithm it wasn't just
getting upvotes it was down voting
everything else so they started
automating it they started using troll
Farms you see those videos where people
have like a hundred cell phones on the
wall and they're walking over and
they're posting messages that's how they
do it and so they would load up Reddit
they would go down vote down vote down
down vote everything in competition with
it on each of their accounts from
different phones and then all of a
sudden not only is this video getting
100 upvotes everything else got
downvotes and boom your video made the
front page right crazy right and this
was like news like 10 years ago yeah
about this
technology has advanced so much can you
imagine seriously seriously ritual
Studio says Universe 25 is becoming a
reality
what's that I don't know no idea no idea
hmm
Paul lamb says I'm 24 looking at all
this woke crap and all I can think about
is preparing to move to the middle of
the woods and building a home for my
future family
I'm telling you man if you if you got
out of the city and then you got
chickens and got a little house you're
probably sitting pretty in your rocking
chair on the porch looking at your
glorious chicken wealth just purchased
uh solar power battery all right I
purchased a thousand what is a thousand
watt generator and a solar generator
solar generator
200 Watts well we have uh we have a
whole bunch of these big batteries with
solar panels yeah I got one kind of one
of those you let the panels and it was
really cool when we first bought them we
uh this was a couple years ago we laid
out like 12 panels and we watched the
thing charge up and the battery was like
charged to full in three hours and
that's actually pretty crazy that's a
lot of electricity being generated and
so we actually I mean we had a lot of
panels it was a huge space being covered
but you could run an air conditioner off
that these little batteries up on the
ground we actually did one day the power
went out here and it was super hot in
the studio and we ran the air
conditioner ran I think for like 45
minutes off of one fully charged battery
so
you know that's pretty good get one it
was a thousand dollars if the apocalypse
happens I'm not gonna be wasting my I'm
not gonna waste my electricity on air
conditioning unless I absolutely have to
for some reason also your phone is a
battery keep that in mind like my solar
panels uh they have USBC ports on them
so you can just plug your phone right
into the panel and it is a battery that
you can use uh you said move out of the
country but where would you move to I
don't know I'm thinking about it if it
gets really bad then I might consider it
I really liked Russia when I went there
El Salvador okay yeah Bitcoin yeah
crimes dropping the standard of living
is increasing it's uh sounded pretty
good Max Kaiser and Stacy Herbert are
like Superstars there right now that's
right so if I had to choose any other
country I just choose that I'd hit up
Max and Stacy and be alive what's going
on bitcoin yo I'm your new neighbor yeah
Bitcoin what about you
I don't know I I um I have a surgeon I I
think both have a couple different
citizenships and so I grew up with this
idea that like if one of the countries
was really bad I could jump to the next
one or they both woke well I'm a British
Canadian and American so it's not
looking good for us I'm not totally sure
where I'll go after this but uh I that
idea that like you could leave or like
that this country wasn't forever it's
like definitely something I grew up with
you know because that's why my parents
left the countries they were in yeah all
right radioactive rat says Tim for the
reverse Shark Tank I work for a tiny
animal shelter in Northern California
one of the poorest counties in the state
as a rep of the shelter could I request
specific donations we desperately need
uh right now
I don't I mean I don't know what to say
the idea I had was people are ragging on
Mr Beast they were calling it demonic
yeah what he did and I'm like it's
insane we can do MILF Manor or we can do
Mr Beast cures blindness I'll take Mr
Beast any day of the week yeah so I I
said on the on the segment we should do
a reverse
um Shark Tank uh reverse uh uh what's
altruistic sure I think is that what
it's called The Shark Tank what's the
show
Dragon's Den and shark attack dragon's
Den's the British version of it reverse
Shark Tank where uh it's a bunch of
philanthropists and people go in to
express why they need charitable
donations I think we'd want to refrain
from people who are like my dad's dying
of kidney failure needs because that's
like really horrible to make someone
come and beg to save someone's life but
we want to keep it as a possibility I
think it's more so like it's foundations
and billionaires and non-profits come in
and talk about the work they're doing so
it's basically like I run a charity that
saves animals last year we saved three
thousand dogs by providing them
emergency kidney dialysis and they went
on to live for five years with your
contribution of x amount of dollars and
then the whales because they're not
sharks because whales are nice we'll
determine how much they want to give and
if they do and it'll be very similar
it'll be like how much what do your
expenses every year how much of the
money that I donate goes to the actual
cause of helping these animals versus
paying your administrative costs and
then they'll say it's 20 which is you
know really really really really really
great uh 80 of the contribute of the
money goes towards and I I think that's
the way to do it yeah because that would
be that that show would function as the
money source for people like Mr Beast
that don't have money that he someone
will come and be like I have a plan to
cure a thousand people's blindness with
this technology this is the surgeries
and then the the charity can fund the
process and you can do it thematically
like one episode is all animal related
right and then you can contrast like how
different services are helping this it's
basically just the same show but with
non-profits I mean Shark Tank could even
do that and have an episode where it's
Charities that come in and say we run a
charity that does these things we are
looking for 500 000 to open a new
building that will provide you know
children with with meals and a warm bed
it's it's impact investment it is the
dawn of the impact investment age I
think it's a great idea yeah great idea
and then I was saying you know we should
uh have a marketing movement where
companies use their marketing budgets to
compete for doing the best thing so I
will pledge this
depending on how much revenue we
generate this year we will not be buying
Times Square billboards
instead we will use our marketing budget
to I don't know make a video where we
cure blindness just rip off Mr Beast
because if everyone started doing that
we'd have no blind people or with
cataracts at least well you can do
something like that we could uh use our
marketing budget to do something
really cool impactful yeah yeah helping
injured athletes you know PRP
platelet-rich plasma things like that
all kinds of things I mean that's
expensive there's probably people more
in need we could we could help and
problems we could solve well and there
are probably people you've had on the
show who would partner with you to do
stuff right better idea we buy
five five hundred thousand lottery
tickets
oh yeah and give them out and somebody's
bound to win the lottery you know and
then use that money towards whatever no
no they can do whatever they want you
know it's like we just give out lottery
tickets that's right that's our that's
our philanthropy we're a non-profit that
gives homeless people lottery tickets
ooh fingers crossed
no but you know I I think we'll do that
I think instead of buying Billboards we
will produce a video akin to a Mr Beast
charitable giving because someone said
put your money where your mouth is Tim
if Mr Beast is doing it you're saying
people should you should and I'm like
okay yeah right let's figure it out
we'll figure out what to do yeah the
thing about the blindness thing as well
Ian is that it's really cheap and the
surgery takes like 10 minutes oh wow
very it's not really that expensive and
it like you know obviously it's
expensive a couple Grand but some people
don't have a couple Grand and it takes
like 10 minutes so that's why they chose
that to be like the thing they would do
for a lot of people you know man let's I
kick it into overdrive if it's that easy
to do and people just need a little
Kickstart yeah yes all right Kobe
Johnson says Tim long time fan since the
old Studio days you should get Peter
zahan on one evening get great insight
into geopolitics and the end of
globalization Ian could have a field day
talking about graphing look them up
maybe we should uh he was on Rogan a
couple weeks ago
on Rogan that's so funny right on top of
it we're running down the street making
a move
amenthy says bill in Last of Us was gay
in the game but it wasn't a focus and
his relationship with Frank was strained
Bill also doesn't die in the game I like
Offerman in the role but I hate these
changes yeah I think in the game what
happened like Frank got bit and then
bailed to kill him or something no idea
something like that
all right Merle gray says the reason why
all the scenes y'all described with the
dad and the notebook get the emotion of
love how how to use because it involves
a sacrifice just like when Jesus Christ
died on the cross
I mean that's kind of what I was saying
like I I I don't you know seeing like
two grown adult men I don't feel
anything over that loss because I view
them both as
self-sufficient capable right men and
it's like it also seems cheesy and corny
forced yeah forced well and I think
there's nothing Noble in this yes
there's nothing that we're alike man if
I were in that circumstance like I hope
that I have the character to like like
he's letting someone who's apparently
dying die and then he's also killing
himself so he doesn't have to deal with
the postpocket right and the political
motive behind it yeah it's just overtly
woke yeah that turn people off probably
there's there's no actual love building
in it like there's nothing I see that
actually shows a relationship of love I
just maybe it's because they're both men
or maybe it's because they just didn't
write it well enough that's the problem
with a lot of Modern Art is they tell
you that they're in love and then you're
supposed to have feelings but they don't
actually play it out over the course of
the process like I'll put it this way
episode 2 Tess sacrifices herself to
save them and there's this really
disgusting scene where the zombie is the
fungus is coming out of its mouth and
then he kisses her and it's going into
down her throat or whatever but like I
think her name's Anna tour of the
actress her emotion and her acting in
the I'm gonna sacrifice myself for you
and she's knocking over like fuel cans
or whatever it's like you can feel it
and then it's really sad when it blows
up and then Joel is like the one thing
he had in this destroyed world is now
dead but like this this this episode
with these two guys there's like
literally nothing there there it shows
them arguing with each other were they
both healthy like nothing not in the end
in the end one guy was sick and dying
he's like in a wheelchair or something
okay how was Bella Ramsey in that show
she's cool yeah she's good I think the
show's really good look I think that
episode was really really good I just I
don't connect with that emotionally I
just can't understand it I'm not trying
to be a dick it's just like if it was a
woman and a man there would be a dynamic
there I would relate to or understand
and maybe that's just me but I will say
this that movie Bros where it's like a
gay or outcome yeah flopped Billy Ike if
you're going to do a gay romance thing
The Last of Us episode three is how you
would do it like the guy the prepper guy
isn't actually gay he's he's been alone
for three years Humanity's been wiped
out and then when this guy shows up I
guess who is gay he's like I've only
never been with a girl or whatever and
so it's like it's a weird dynamic I
guess it's interesting but it's like the
Bros movie was just weird
lewd yeah kind of over-the-top gross I
think people are just seeing it too much
it's Overexposed right because I think
there was that Disney movie with the gay
character or something that was supposed
to be you know you know like a big hit
but then it completely flopped
everywhere and then didn't do well at
the box office so I think people are
just fed up of the
uh you know over political messages in
in culture and in Hollywood I think I
think the issue is it's just relatable
to a very very very small portion of the
population yes if if it was his brother
in this and it's like you know one day
he he sees his trap his sprung he looks
out and he sees his brother's there and
he's like oh my God John where have you
been and then right it's like he's
smiling and he's like I've been alone
for three years and you made it back I
thought you died and then in the end his
brother's dying like I would relate to
that and be like oh man that's so sad
you know it sounds like um like a gay
fantasy if they wrote it like gay guy
meets straight guy but straight guy
falls in love with him
now he's gay too that's what I think too
yeah anyway anyway let's read some more
all right Curtis says when Putin said
something to the effect of America is
full of satanists I couldn't disagree
knowing that poor uh couldn't
necessarily know that porn is one of
America's top exports well a lot of
people feel that way yeah
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats Rod undefined rod says Tim the gun
channels have been destroyed by YouTube
this past week they even struck Ian
McCollum for a suppressor video
misspelled deliberate
um we are we are planning on having uh
some people on talk about this so uh
yeah we'll see I don't want to say too
much because we're in the process of
booking everything I don't know when
it's going to happen but they're
tweeting about it I just went to YouTube
Tim Poole calls out Hassan ABI what is
this calls out
Tim Poole calls out Hassan ABI it's
Hassan's on Hassan's Channel what I
didn't I agree with Hassan come on man
Hassan wrote that yeah I think it's on
his show calls out I literally agree
with him like four or five times I think
he's right yeah but if you agree with
you're not gonna as many clicks come on
Tim he says as I call him out a temple
calls out Hassan ABI yeah shout out
maybe yep I was like Hassan complaining
about how it's How Some YouTube guys got
to make this video he's right yeah
that's a good point that if Assad was
like Tim if the title was Tim pulls
pretty cool
I disagree I think at this point if
Hassan wrote Tim Poole actually agrees
with Hassan over Mr Beast people would
click it to be like yo what's the word
agree is really big
I don't I I it was the craziest thing
when when Hassan's like I'm this fills
me with rage that it's up some YouTube
guy to to get just get to give these
people this 10 minute procedure and I'm
like he's right yeah why why is our
society where we've we need
entertainment in the form of helping
people this 10-minute procedure why
can't we figure out a way to solve the
problems that are happening in this
country totally yeah so I I don't know
if I agree with him on the solution to
these problems but he's right to call
out as a as a look I will take Mr Beast
over MILF Manor any day but I think we
can do better and as long as we're
giving 100 billion dollars to Ukraine
someone pointed out let's just give 2.5
million dollars to every uh homeless
veteran oh yeah someone said sure how
about we give you 500 000 and Mr Beast
gave uh solved a hundred thousand or a
thousand people's blindness he could
have bought out M1 Abram for the
ukrainians what was he thinking
that's a good one yeah at Ukraine isn't
going to stop anytime soon no that's for
sure I I gotta I gotta I gotta look at
that video yeah I'm gonna watch it I'll
send it I think I said like I I disagree
with them politically on like how we we
solve it but he's completely right about
that being an issue and people are
ragging on him it's like he's not mad at
Mr Beast yeah he's met like the system
and I agree he's gotten under your skin
that's the market that's the magic of
his marketing and titling here yeah I'm
pissed that we gave 100 billion dollars
to Ukraine before fixing our bridges our
roads our pipes our schools you got kids
drinking lead and all this other garbage
and then these leftists come out and
they're like can we fix these pipes and
everyone's like yes yeah yes actually we
agree with fixing the infrastructure in
this country instead for some reason our
politicians just go blow up kids
overseas yeah anyway but now the
leftists are saying we can do both we
can fix the lead pipes and and we can
Aid Ukraine because you know just print
more money I don't know maybe maybe
that's why he's saying like I didn't
criticize him but maybe he's criticizing
me because I said we shouldn't be
funding the war in Ukraine and we should
be funding I'm telling you this title
has really gotten you he's won yeah I
saw this meme remember when the uh
Donald Trump said he was they were
saying he was going to cause World War
III and now they're like yeah let's
start World War Three yeah all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
over at timcast.com so you can check out
our uncensored members only show that's
coming up in about one hour we record it
right after we wrap here and then we
upload it and it's not so family
friendly you can follow the show at
timcastirl everywhere you can follow at
timcast news on Twitter do it you can
follow me personally everywhere at
timcast Samir do you want to shout
anything out
um yes follow me on Twitter Twitter at
samiricon
s-a-m-e-e-r-a-k-h-a-n and tune in for
the uh after show right on well I'm
Hannah Claire I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should go to timcast.com
and click on the read tab to see
articles from me and the rest of our
team you can follow me personally at on
Instagram Hannah claire.be you can
follow me on Twitter at hcbrillow and
you should definitely follow at timcast
news on Twitter it's excellent go there
immediately I'm Ian cross and follow me
on the internet anywhere you can find
Ian cross on I'm probably that guy and
God prayers to the people of denipro Up
and Down the River and Curson it's a
rough
it's a rough uh it's the best for all
those people everyone there healthy calm
make it happen
and yeah you can find me anywhere at
surge.com I took a poll and see if you
guys like to see my music in the future
we'll see how that pull goes and I'll
abide by that but uh yeah it was a good
show thanks guys see you in the after we
will see all of you over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out cheers